[Musique]
messieurs bonsoir bonsoir nous vous
recevons pour une chaî inter s'appellew
nous sommes en direct est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succintement loï
FL pr industriel
c'est tout c'est tout ça marche si
jamais on peut après on peut faire un
roman industriel voilà c'est donc jeune
entrepreneur l FL je entrepreneur et et
nous avons Nicolas Manan Nicolas man moi
je suis obligé de faire cours donc
entrepreneur entrepreneur entrepreneur
un petit background un peu dans
l'énergie un peu d'énergie un peu de
voiture électrique un peu de transport
et une facette que les gens connaissent
moins c'est l'entrepreneuriat parce que
je à mi-temps je travaille avec ma femme
dans pour essayer à notre petite
contribution de réindustrialiser notre
pays comment elle s'appelle la boîte de
ta femme elle s'appelle aréjane et elle
fait elle fait quoi elle fait des
culottes menstruelles made in France et
donc c'est la plus grande marque de
l'ingerie française et c'est aussi la
plus petite puisque c'est la seule bon
on va parler tout ça ce soir on va
parler produire en France on va même pas
parler de réindustrialisation peut-être
que si bah c'est trop tôt c'est trop tôt
de parler réindustrialisation il faut
d'abord savoir si on peut produire et on
va parler aussi géopolitique on va
parler énergie on va parler perspective
et on va parler surtout sauver le pays
on va commencer avec le jeune loïque
la perception de produire en France à
l'heure actuelle vous en tant que petit
entrepreneur
quelles sont les difficultés que vous
rencontrez de tous ordre mais la
première difficulté c'est que on a
l'impression d'avoir en face de nous des
gens qui nous empêchent en face de nous
c'estàdire que c'est l'ensemble de
l'administration l'ensemble des
politique l'ensemble des commentateurs
envie de nous empêcher de de de de
produire je vous coupez oui mais c'est
peut-être un épiphénomène que vous avez
rencontré sur une seule boîte parce
qu'il y a plein de fonctionnaires qui
essayent d'aider les entrepreneurs pour
fluidifier les choses maximiser
l'efficacité des procédures je me fais
l'avocat du diable il y a quand même des
B
le problème c'est que j'ai j'ai SEP
boîtes dans des endroits différents donc
j'ai un peu de mal à considérer que je
suis une exception parce que ça fait 7
exception une collection chanoire ouis
c'est ça peut-être mais mais puis mes
copains aussi ils sont dans le même état
et puis les copains de mes copains aussi
et puis les endroits où je suis puisque
par exemple je suis à au mouvement
éthique patronal ils ont la même le même
sentiment hein je suis vice-président du
mouvement éthique et il se trouve que
tous les gens me disent bah oui c'est
bien ça il nous empêche et et donc c'est
quand même dramatique d'arriver détail
c'est quoi qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans le
détail c'est quoi B dans le détail
c'està dire que vous avez
les des fonctionnaires qui vous les les
PIR les pires c'est les direction
régional de l'environnement alors ça
c'est les pires parce que ils ont envie
d'éviter que vous produisiez ils sont
contents quand vous produisez pas ils
sont contents ça c'est caricatural mais
c'est pas caricatural c'est vrai c'est
moi j'ai quand quand j'ai il y a une
boîte que j'ai fermé j'étais félicité
oui c'est ben c'est sale c'éit une boîte
sale alorson fallait mieux la fermer
alors boî quoi c'est une boîte de quo
c'est une boîte de de mécanique mais
c'était sale c'est çaon faisait de la
peinture oui la peinture c'est
abominable he donc peindre peindre c'est
c'est très compliqué ça c'est c'est
c'est sale c'est parce que il faut que
vous mettiez vous calculiez bien que
toute la peinture va quelque part donc
vous avez 1 kg de peinture vous le
mettez sur le métal puis après il y a un
endroit où la peinture descend puis
derrière on essaie de voir si il y a
bien autant de peinture dessus que non
et qu'on n pas mis quelque part dans la
fameuse na pratique donc c'est donc tout
ça c'est très compliqué pour me faire
l'avocat du diable mais bien sûr moi je
me ser aussi la col du diable aussi il y
a peut-être eu plein de scandales
industriels oou certains se sont un peu
lâchés dans les rivières ou que il y a
peut-être certaines normes qui ont été
un petit peu
ils ont louvoyé avec la normalité de la
nor c'est facile c'est facile c'est
facile c'està dire que vous avez un code
du travail qui existe depuis 1910 alors
déjà on dit qu'il est compliqué hein
alors il est en page
de playade là vous voyez vous avez il
est comme ça bon puis vous avez un autre
code qui est le code de l'environnement
code d'environnement il a la même taille
même taille il existe depuis 20 ans et à
l'intérieur du code vous avez des
injonctions contradictoires faut vous
fassiez quelque chose puis vous fiez
l'inverse et puis ça dépend de l'article
alors bon vous avez concret de façon de
façon concrète
lorsque vous avez une un logement qui
est une passeur thermique bien il faut
que vous fassiez des doubl vitrag mais
si jamais vous êtes dans une protégée
vous avez pas le droit de changer les
fenêtresz c'est c'est donc donc tout
dépend que de toute façon toute façon
vous avez tort vousz tort selon
l'article de du du code de
l'environnement et c'est partout sur
l'ensemble pareil c'estàd que par
exemple j'ai j'ai j'ai une fonderie j'ai
une fonderie j'ai une fonderie business
sale j'ai une fond quoi encore un
business sale une fonderie une fonderie
alors dans la fonderie
bien sûr alors de fondr et il peut y
avoir des incendis très bien alors si
jamais il y a un incendi et bien vous
pouvez pas mettre de l'eau
explose pourquoi parce que ça explose ok
alors vous diteson mais je je peux pas
mettre de l'eau ah oui mais si jamais il
y a de l'eau et si jamais il y a un et
qu'on met de l'eau je dis à ce momentl
ça explose ah oui mais il faut quand
même que vous ayez un réceptacle pour ne
pas mélanger les eaux qui éteindraient
l'incendie des EAU des EAU de pluies je
d'accord mais il y aura jamais d'eau
mais si il peut y avoir de l'eau mais c
l'au il y a de l'eau de plie oui mais il
y aura jamais d'eau pour éteindre
l'incendi mais ça faiten c'est le
règlement mais c'est règlement de quoi
est-ce qu'il y a pas un moment une une
manière de considérer que
plus synthétique si vous aviez à faire
remonter une doléance en en terme de de
chef d'entreprise en terme de
entrepreneur
est-ce qu'on peut faire remonter d'une
façon bien formulée uneance il faut
repigner complètement le code les codes
du travail mais surtout de
l'environnement et puis faire en sorte
que il y a des choses simples qui soient
dites et que on demande à l'entrepreneur
de résour résoudre le problème et non
pas de d'atteindre le code le code c'est
c'est ça doit être quelque chose qui
correspond à un objectif si jamais
j'arrive à l'objectif mais que j'emploie
une autre méthode que celle qui a été
élaborée dans le code que ça peut faire
donc revenons à l'objectif l'objectif
c'est que l'environnement soit préservé
alors très bien je je suis d'accord
l'environnement est préservé il faut
éviter d'avoir très bien je suis
d'accord prenons l'objectif et puis
maintenant euh les les industriels sont
suffisamment intelligents pour savoir
derrière comment il faut faire pour
atteindre l'objectif mais là on natteint
pas l'objectif et ceci est vrai de
l'environnement ceci est vrai de
quantité de choses dans sur le plan
énergétique sur le plan sur le plan du
travail sur le plan quel est l'objectif
et et et on on oublie l'objectif c'estd
on oublie l'objectif tout le temps
c'estàdire qu'on sait plus quel est
l'objectif on on a en face de nous des
gens qui n'ont pas d'objectif autre que
de de remplir les tableaux Excel en
disant voilà comment il faut faire
puisque c'est marqué dans ce que je dois
faire avec vous Nicolas c'est très
intéressant ce que lï soulève en tant
que jeune entrepreneur
est-ce que nos patrons nos chefs
d'entreprise
eux qui ont un objectif qui est de faire
tourner la boîte faire vivre les
salariés payer leur cotisation sociale
et avancer et surtout survivre dans un
contexte très de de prédation dramatique
vous en tant que toi en tant que chef
d'entreprise associé
qu'est-ce que tu rencontres comme
problème
moi je voulais juste revenir un peu par
rapport à ce que disait disait louig
parce que effectivement
quelques chiffres pour placer du
contexte
la France on est quand même si on
regarde l'industrie manufacturière au
niveau de la Grèce donc on est un pays
de tourisme puisquon est à moins de 10 %
du PIB industrie manufacturière donc on
n pas la alimentaire on est le pays qui
a le plus désindustrialisé en Europe
depuis euh depuis 40 ans euh on avait un
autre pays qui était aussi mauvais que
nous mais qui ne fait plus partie de
l'Europe qui s'appelle les Royaume-Unis
et quand on regarde par exemple les
émissions de CO2 en fait on est dans un
pays où la seule façon qu'on est trouvé
pour faire baisser nos émissions de CO2
c'est de fermer les usines donc on est
très bon on ferme les usines on réduit
les émissions de CO2 on réduit la
pollution et puis tu te retrouves dans
un monde sans usine et puis par contre
quand tu regardes quand même ton
emprunte de carbone donc ton impact sur
le climat là il faut quand même compter
les émissions importées d'ailleurs et là
celles-là bah elles ont elles ont
presque doublé elles ont presque doublé
et donc aujourd'hui la moitié de notre
empreinte sur le climat c'est nos
émissions apportées alors ça bien sûr on
en parle jamais on ne parle que de nos
émissions et et nos émissions bah depuis
95 c'est pas dur quel est le seul
secteur qui a baissé c'est l'industrie
de moitié parce qu'on a fermé les usines
on a fermé on a fait un peu d'efficacité
énergétique et donc aujourd'hui voilà le
problème c'est qu'on est dans un pays
alors ça marche pour l'industrie ça
marche aussi un peu pour le nucléaire
parce qu'en fait on a tout fait pour
pour tuer notre industrie on a tout fait
pour tuer notre nucléaire mais on a
besoin les deux quoi non mais ça veut
dire quoi on a tout fait c'est qui on
bah c'est les réglementations c'est que
toutes les normes qui sont empilées les
unes sur les autres on peut prendre
l'exemple de l'pr qui est qui est un
réacteur bon qui s'est fait sur une
une mauvaise idée je pense de d'an
levergeon un peu suggéré par
non pas selon moi parce que c'est c'est
helmou Cole qui vient voir François
mitteran à la fin des années 80 début
d'années 90 qui arrive avec Siemens qui
est en faillite parce que EDF a gagné
tous les contrats à l'exportation dans
les années 80 et qui dit ben voilà
qu'est-ce qu'on fait est-ce que sera on
ferait pas un Airbus du nucléaire ce
serait fantastique et là forc
je crois que le le mur de B venait de
tomber et donc l'auvergeon trouvait ça
génial François mitteran aussi et donc
alors qu'on avait le pays qui avait
qu'on avait déjà construit une
quarantaine peut-être une cinquantaine
de réacteurs nucléaires qu'on était
qu'on avait le seul pays qui avait
améliorer en continu notre technologie
on décide de tout mettre à la poubelle
pour construire un truc avec des
Allemands mixer deux autorités de sûreté
empiler des HES les unes sur les autres
et créer un monstre qui s'appelle le Pr
d' qui d'abord s'appelit pr voulait dire
européen depuis ça a changé puisque dès
la fin des années 90 les Allemands sont
désengagés du nucléaire et donc on reste
coincé dans ce truc on en faire le Pr on
va faire le PR2 mais concrètement on a
sacrifié notre filière industrielle moi
je dis souvent alors je suis pas un
expert du nucléaire et moins cloïque
mais j'ai l'impression que on était à la
fin des années 90 chez DF on avait
développé quelque chose qui s'appelait
le REP 2000 réacteur ha pressurisé de
l'an 2000 ou le N 4 plus c'était le Pali
N4 mais CELI d'après qu'on avait donc
années d'expérience 2500 années
d'expérience réacteur et que ça on l'a
mis à la poubelle pour pour faire
plaisir aux Allemands quoi euh et ça je
c'est quelque chose qui m'échappe c'est
votre interprétation parce que on n'est
pas du genre à vouloir faire plaisir aux
Allemands bah pour le coup je pense que
Monsieur monsieur monsieur mitéan était
très content peut-être pour initier
faire le premier ou le deuxième enfant
avec les Allemands parce que le premier
c'était Ctait un bus je sais pas mais
on revient on revient à mon propos dans
ce que dit dans ce que Nicolas c'està
dire que on se trompe on se trompe
d'objectif c'est à un moment quel est
l'objectif industrielle
et économique c'est de produire une
énergie abondante et bon marché on a
l'outil l'outil c'est le nucléaire qu'on
a développé et on fait une énergie abond
des bon marchés soudain on dit non
l'objectif c'est de faire du
franco-allemand parce que ce serait bien
du point de vue
du point de vue politique ben très bien
c'est c'est un objectif mais est-ce
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour faire du
franco-allemand non on à ce moment-là on
change tout on change tout on oublie
tout ce qu'on a fait et on dit oui c'est
vrai c'est l'objectif c'est d'être
franco-allemand qui était un objectif
ENI qui a qui a qui qui a pas marché
puisque dans quelques années après il
fallait plus faire du franco-allemand
parce que les Allemands avaient envie de
se tirer mais voyez donc c'est on se
trompe on se trompe sans arrêt sur quel
est l'objectif et quelle est mesure
qu'on prend par rapport à l'objectif
l'objectif l'objectif qui est clair
c'est que nous avons besoin d'une
énergie abondante et bon marché pour
pouvoir avoir une industrie florissante
dans tous les secteurs c'est comme ça
j'ai envie de dire merci Sherlock Holmes
pour cette richiche déduction moi j'ai
une question plus simple basique c'est
qui on
quelle est la chaîne de commandement de
la planification énergétique qui et on
qui ont alors le le on c'est à un moment
le pouvoir politique puisque on est dans
une nous sommes en France dans une
situation où il y avait un monopole et
petit 1 et de parce que les grandes
infrastructures c'est toujours d'une
certaine façon l'État qui les décide
quel qu'il soit les ce sont les états le
fameux plan le plan ou pas le plan
c'estàd que si jamais aujourd'hui en en
Californie on dit voilà il faut
l'électricité pour tout le monde à un
moment c'est un état qui dit oui il faut
l'électricité pour tout le monde alors
on avait dit en Californie on enlève on
enlève le nucléaire et on fait autre
chose et puis à un moment il y a eu il y
a eu la panne complète et on est revenu
au nucléaire donc il y a bien un état
qui fait et l'État un objectif cet
objectif
est recommandable c'estàd que j'ai envie
d'avoir pour mon pays une énergie
abondante bon marché c'est c'est un bon
objectif bon soudain on change
l'objectif on dit c'est plus ça c'est il
faut
faire du franco-allemand puis
aujourd'hui dans dans les dans les
dernières années on a dit il faut faire
l'objectif c'est de faire des énergies
renouvelables parce que celles-là sont
propres alors un on peut s'interroger
pour savoir si elles sont propres
vraiment de si elles sont vraiment en
carbone intéressant et tr quel est
l'objectif là c'est est-ce que c'est
toujours abondant et bon marché ou
est-ce que c'est o on a pu ça c'est pas
abondant et pas bon marché et on se
retrouve effectivement dans la situation
aujourd'hui où on dit bah il va y avoir
pénurieélectricité et donc il va falloir
que vous soyez sobre ah très bien
parfait c'est sobre je croyais qu'on av
on avait l'électricité vous en avz pas
avir beaucoup vous faites quand même de
la voiture électrique parce que voiture
électrique c'est bien puis vous faites
de la pompe à chaleur parce que la pompe
à chaleur c'est bien trs bien alors vous
avez pas d'électricité vous êtes en
pénurie vous devez être sobre mais vous
allez faire de la voiture électrique et
et vous allez et et vous allez faire de
la Prome à chaleur très bien quelle est
la cohérence de tout ça alors je crois
que la cohérence à un moment c'est
toujours de dire quel est l'objectif et
c'est ça que je cherche en tant
qu'industriel je dis vous êtes en train
de me dire que par exemple il faut
réindustrialiser très bien mais je suis
d'accord il faut réindustrialiser
puisque comme l'a dit très bien Nicolas
nous sommes au niveau de la Grèce très
bien alors maintenant est-ce qu'on
pourrait commencer par savoir si votre
action n'est pas en train de faire
l'inverse c'estàd et moi en tant
qu'industriel vous dit ben finalement
dans ce que vous me dites pour
réindustrialiser moi j'entends le fait
qu'il faut que je déménage dit par
exemple à un moment on dit vous allez
faire dans l'année 10 % d'économie
d'énergie dans votre industrie autrement
vous allez avoir des sanctions moi
je fais des économies d'énergie tous les
jours parce que je paye l'énergie bon
donc j'ai fait mes économies énergie je
sais faire l'économie d'énergie quelle
est la manière de faire des économie
d'énergie en plus ben c'est de déménager
déménager dans un autre pays et c'est ça
et c'est ça que c'est ça le point
important c'estàd que on nous dit vous
avez vous vous avez un moyen qui est
simple c'est fait les économies a des
exantions c'estàdire que punition vous
êtes punis et et la bonne façon de faire
c'est dire bah finalement puisque je
suis puni ici allons ailleurs lorsque
patriotique ça mais mais c'est pas
patriotique mais c'est et c'est la
réponse à la question on a lorsque
lorsqu'on nous a dit il faut diminuer la
consommation parce qu'on va avoir un
problème à l'hiver précédent et il y a
des industriels qui ont répondu mais on
va faire qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait alors
ils ont fait ben ils ont coupé dans la
production et ils ont fait la production
ailleurs et qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
ben on s'est satisfait on a dit bravo le
gouvernement a dit bravo vous avez
diminué la la production mais la
consommation on a dit la consommation et
de on a diminué également l'industrie
c'est ça l'objectif que vous voulez vous
voulez réindustrialiser et alors on dit
ben on va réindustrialiser parce que on
est en train de faire des projets un
projet c'est pas ce n'est pas une
réalisation donc il faut savoir ce que
vous faites est-ce que vous voulez
multiplier les projets non financés ou
est-ce que vous voulez faire de
l'industrie si vousit si vous voulez
faire de l'industrie d'abord il faut
conserver l'industrie qui existe
aujourd'hui il y a des gens qui se qui
se battent tous les jours pour faire de
l'industrie faut vous arriviez comment
vous allez faire vous allez faire que
vous ayez une administration qui essaie
de voir comment conserver cette
industrie c'est une industrie que
j'appellerai bienveillante qui a envie
de conserver l'industrie mais si jamais
vous avez une administration ne
serait-ce que 10 % 15 % 20
%administration si vous considérez qu'il
y a des gentils dans l'administration si
vous avez une administration qui vous
dit
moi je ne pense pas moi je moi je vois
pas mais et peut-être que vous vous les
voyez vous avez des des gens
bienveillants dans l'administration qui
en CH exemple très très récent quelqu'un
qui travaill au fisque absolument très
pédagogique très sympa carré cubique
très professionnel pour connecter les
taes c'est très très bien et et et et en
plus il donneent des tuyaux pour que ça
se passe mieux la prochaine fois
ouiinaire ben ça ça c'est très bien mais
alors montrezles- moi et envoyez-les moi
chez moi parce que c'est moi chez moi
j'ai pas ça moi j'ai j'ai chez moi j'ai
la la porte non c'est soit vous faites
ça et vous investissez des sommes
importantes soit on
mise en demeure et on ferme votre boîte
j'ai très bien si si jamais c'est ça le
jeu B à la fin il y a pas d'autre
solution que de fermer la boîte alors
juste un détail vous avez été quand même
un peu patron
oui tu connais ce que c'est d'être
patron de boîteah ça fait ça fait
maintenant bah oui ça fait 4 an qui
quand la chaîne de commandement est
d'une vacuité
égale
au plus grand néant
le patron il assume la décision oui mais
il cherche où la chaîne de commandement
a été défaillante oui est-ce que c'est
le cas là est-ce qu'il y a une il y a
pas de responsable a jamais de
responsable je n'ai jamais responsable
le responsable c'est quelqu'un qui a une
feuille de papier et qui me dit c'est le
chef et et le chef il a dit que ou le
gouvernement a dit que ou c'est ça moi
ma feuille ma feuille de route c'est ça
et et il y a pas de responsable et si
jamais à la limite il y a un le la seule
façon de faire c'est de se protéger si
jamais il y a un incident ou un accident
et c'est la feuille de papier qui
protège donc je suis pas responsable par
la feille de papier nonon et et et ça je
peux je je ne supporte plus cette cette
façon de de procéder qui n'existe pas
dans d'autres dans d'autres régions
c'est lorsque dans région du monde
c'estàdire que le bangladesch
banglad
je n'y pas dans d'autres régions du
monde où il y a de l'industrie et où
est-ce que où il y a des normes aussi
non il y a pas de norme il y a pas de
nor dans d'autres régions du monde mais
quand je vous suis moi je me fais pas la
je vous dis je vous parle de l'Allemagne
la Suisse l'Italie et les gens qui nous
entourent donc je vais là-bas je vais
voir les industriels et bon finalement
j'ai des j'ai des gens qui disent bah
oui voilà on discute et on trouve et on
trouve des des des façons de faire de
manière pas trop investir pourquoi
est-ce que par exemple vous avez eu tous
les principes actifs qui sont par des
médicaments qui sont partis pourquoi
vous avez les principes actifs on vous
dit bah c'est simple parce que il
fallait absolument ils étaient moins
chers ailleurs ah qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire moins cher et aussitôt on dit vous
connaz le les les travailleurs français
sont beaucoup plus chers que ceux de
l'Inde ou de la Chine ok c'est ça la
raison c'est pas ça la raison du tout la
raison c'est que les investissements qui
étaient demandés aux gens qui faisaient
des principes actifs pour conserver les
principes des actifs en France était
trop important et conduisait à relever
le prix bon relever le prix alors le
prix ça faut dire quoi si jamais
j'augmente le prix du principes actif
j'augmente le prix des médicaments je
prends le médicaments par conséquent je
demande au à
au fonctionnaires qui donneent le prix
du médicament de relever le prix ils
disent non alors si jamais vous reprenez
la chaîne dans l' sens si le prix du
médicament n'augmente pas le prix du
actif n'augmente pas je n'ai pas d'autre
choix que d'aller le faire ailleurs et
c'est ce qui s'est passé et donc moi
quand j'étais patron des boîtes de de
pharmacie il y avait 80 % des principes
actifs qui étaient fait en France et
aujourd'hui il y en a 20 % et et ça
continue parce que parce qu'il y a pas
de raison de faire des principes actif
si jamais vous n'avez pas une
correspondance entre le prix du
médicament qu'on vous rembourse et le le
la façon dont on vous a demandé de faire
un investissement important voilà
je regardais aujourd'hui les chiffres de
de l'emploi dans l'industrie on a perdu
2 million et demi d'emplois depuis le
premier choc pétrolier et en fait moi je
suis un peu d'accord et je crois que
c'est un peu l'histoire de de l'usine on
avait en France une des usines qui qui
raffinait les terres rares qui était l'
usine de rô Poulin à La Rochelle à La
Rochelle monus c'était ton usine ah
c'était mon usine oui c'était l'usine
qui était une des usines les plus
produit
les plus intéressantes sur le plan de la
rentabilité c'est clair non mais était
au norme aussi é au normes aussi ta
petite fabrique ah ben c'est dire les
normes il y avait on a fait on a fait
l'usine au départ c'est pas maises
prédécessession on fait l'usine de de La
Rochelle bon alors ensuite les normes se
sont abattu et et ben à un moment quand
les normes étaient trop importantes on
est reparti a les Chinois les chinois
sont arrivés ils ont dit moi il y a pas
de problème vous pouvez la mettre chez
moi ça me POS aucun souci et ça arrangé
tout le monde ça rrangé les élus locaux
ça manger les citoyens sur place qui
voulit pas que que les déchets soient je
sais pas quoi reversé dans près des
optimistesou je sais pas où bref et donc
mais ça c'est l'histoire de toutes les
usines et c'est comme ça en fait à un
moment donné la Chine a rejoint l'OMC
début début 2000 2001 et elle a dit non
venez mettre les usines chez nous ça
pose pas de problème et nous ça nous
arrangé bien parce que ça nous permetait
de de garder des prix bas voir de faire
baisser les prix et et qu'est-ce qu'on a
fait depuis 20 ans avec ces d
désindustrialisation c'est qu'on a
importé de la déflation et donc en fait
on a donné aux gens l'impression qu'on
préservait ou qu'on augmentait leur
pouvoir d'achat mais aujourd'hui plus
personne n'est capable d'acheter quelque
chose fabriqué en France ça coûte trop
cher donc on les a on le on leur a
préservé leur pouvoir d'acheter du made
in China mais c'est c'est le grand
problème aujourd'hui c'est que si un
jour on veut réindustrialiser et
reproduire en France c'est que ça coûte
cher qui va payer moi je le dis très
franchement je travaille dans dans une
entreprise qui fait du du made in France
al nous je vais raconter l'histoire
rapidement donc c'est des culottes
menstruelles les culottes menstruelles
au départ ça remplace des protections
périodiques jetables donc quand on
arrive et qu'on lance ça il y a 5 ans on
est les premiers et donc même si ça
coûte 35 39 € ça coûte moins cher que de
mettre 5 à 10 € par mois dans des
protections jetables et d'ailleurs les
les premières les premières clientes de
rjan c'est les ouvriers c'est les
couturières c'est les è qui nous les
commande un peu comme fort de vender ses
voitures à ses à ses ouvriers donc très
bien face au jetable on est on est
performant mais derrière au bout de 2
ans on a tout le Made in China madeine
tout tout qui arrive et là là il vendent
à trois fois moins cher que nous et
l'État stratège vous AZ un petit peu
protégé aidé cons l'état stratège moi je
pense que c'est ça l'état stratège il
fait beaucoup de choses pour attirer les
entreprises notamment qui fabriquent des
batteries comme ça on peut faire des
grandes communications mais les gens qui
sont déjà là les industriels qui se
battent tous les jours alors eux il a il
y a rien pour eux il y a juste des
factures d'électricité qui sont
multiplié par 3 par 4 par 10 nous avec
un nos ateliers on est Quême une haosse
de plus 25 % donc c'est pas très
compliqué on coûte trois fois plus cher
que le Portugal 5 fois plus cher que la
Tunisie 7 fois plus cher que la Chine
ne9 fois plus cher que le Vietnam donc
si en plus on a les coûts qui augmentent
on fait partie des des gens qui se
battent et en plus on se fait taper
dessus
quoi on on se fait taper dessus c'est
qui on bah on on a si vous voulez en
France il y avait il y avait un avantage
compétitif c'était le prix de
l'électricité donc ça on l'a perdu l'an
dernier x 3 x 4 x 10 alors nous
l'électricité bah ça nous impacte quand
même mais on parce qu'on a quand même
des machines à coudre et cetera et donc
voilà et donc on se prend on se prend le
seul avantage compétitif la seule raison
pour laquelle les industriels viennent
en France c'est pour ça parce
queélectricité coûte pas cher abondante
fiable bon marché quand on perd cet Atou
là ça devient ça devient compliqué donc
nous on se bat on se bat un peu comm un
exemple là à partir du 1er janvier 2024
ellisabeth borne a annoncé la gratuité
des protections périodiques
réutilisables dans les pharmacies
pour les personnes de moins de 25 ans
bah sur le papier c'est pas une mauvaise
idée mais sans condition ça pe être du
made in China avec duing fiscal
duingation
voilà donc si c'était du mid in France
bah ça pourrait être pertinent quand on
fait un appel d'offre on reçoit un appel
d'offre publque les gens veulent lcher
les culottes il y a aucune clause sur le
mine France donc on reçoit une note on
va gagner un ou deux points parce qu'on
est fabriqué en France c'est pas
interdit l'Union européenne cette petit
sû que si ça interdit par le traité de
traité de Lisbonne par pardon traité de
Rome 1957 et si je dis pas de bêtis
c'est l'article 6 qui interdit la
discrimination entre entre les pays vous
AZ même aujourd'hui j'ai vu Guillaume
gibau qui est le président de Ch
français qui a lancé une pétition
justement pour demand and demander al
lui c'est lui qui a un petit peu lancé
le mine France il y a 10 ans en 2012
pour demander que que que que les
conditions économique soit adapté pour
le fabriquer français mais c'est
impossible c'est interdit c'est interdit
par la loi alors on a on a d'une part
les conditions économiques générales
dont vient de parler Nicolas alors ça
c'est après tout on peut dire vous
connaissez les conditions économique bon
ben tant pis pour vous alors tant pis
pour nous sauf quand ça augmente quand
les impôts augmentent quand
l'électricité augmente on dit là mais ce
qu'il a de pire plus pernicieux c'est
lorsque les normes et règlements sont
existent qu'on les développe à l'excès
et notre notre pays les développe à
l'excès c'est qu'on par exemple par
rapport aux normes européennes on est
toujours mieux que l'Europe on est
toujours bien bien plus bien plus joli B
donc sur on sur suralimente les normes
et ensuite et ensuite on a et ensuite on
a des gens qui regardent ces normes et
qui vont au-delà de de de de ce qu'il de
ce que les normes disent pour encore
faire mieux et c'est là et donc c'est là
c'est là où si jamais on a un progrès à
faire immédiat c'est la question que
vous me posez au départ si on a un
progrès à faire immédiat c'est revenir à
quelque chose qui conduit au moins à ce
que nous ayons une position
réglementaire et normative l'équivalente
de des prod des des productions des gens
qui nous entour aussi bien américaine
que des pays développés au moins ça au
moins qu'on est ça alors on sait qu'on a
un coup du travail un droit du travail
qui est difficile on sait qu'on qu'on a
des
un C nombre de problèmes avec des
machines que nous sommes obligés
d'acheter à l'étranger parce que nous
fabriquons plus en France on sait qu'on
a un certain nombre de boulets au pied
mais mais le problème c'est d'augmenter
ces boulets avec des choses qui n'ont
rien à voirjec avecob présenté
différemment en France on a un droit du
travail oui en France on a pas des pas
souvent ou du moins moins souvent
d'habitude on n pas des rivières qui
changent de couleur en passant par ver
flu jusqu'à violet non bon al après il y
a peut-être des ch ça c'est pas en
France c'est en Europe oui
en Europe pas des coins peu CC bon h
donc quand même toutes ces normes on
servit à quelque chose c'est clair on
serv à quelque chose je vous dis je vous
dis simplement je nai je n'ai rien à
voir je n' je n'ai rien à à contredire
les normes et réglementations je dis que
lorsqu'on a des surnormes et des
surréglementations pour faire plaisir à
soit des députés soit des euh des des
administrations c'est inutile ça ne
répond pas à l'objectif si jamais la
question est que nous devons protéger la
nature je suis d'accord si jamais on me
dit g bien évident et les gens la nature
pour les gens je suis d'accord si jamais
maintenant on me dit les moyens c'est ça
et voilà la norme qu'il faut respecter
et la manière de respecter la norme ça
je dis non c'est pour ça que je vous
posais tout à l'heure l'exemple de du du
problème de l'incendie dans ma fonderie
je n'est pas besoin de répondre à la
norme haut de pluie haut de de
d'extinction dans ma fonderie puisque je
ne peux pas mettre de l'eau d'extinction
donc j'ai je dois avir une dérogation
pas de dérogation donc c'est c'est C
c'est cet élément qui qui est qui est et
ceci est quelque chose que que nous
retrouvons et que nous avons retrouvé
dans le déménagement des principes
actifs de France vers ailleurs alors on
dit c'est simple on va le principe actif
de de l'iprane on va le remettre le
paracétamol on va le remettre en France
mais est-ce que vous gardez la norme ou
pas si vous gardez la norme à ce
moment-là vous avez un prix
supplémentaire correspondant à une norme
est-ce que cette norme est la même de le
côté du rein non bah hier continue à
faire à faire du du passam là-bas
pourquoi il en fait parce que c'est
moins cher du point de vue de la
fabrication parce que c'est pas la même
norme quel est le problème il paraît
qu'il y a une norme européenne ah oui il
y a une norme européenne mais vous
n'appliquez pas la norme européenne la
norme vous appliquez une surnorme par
rapport à l'Europe parce que vous faites
beaucoup mieux parce que vous êtes bien
bien bien plus beau c'est ça le sujet il
est là c'est que on a toujours envie de
faire mieux que les autres d'être plus
plus plus plus et ce n'est pas il y a
une solution une solution et la solution
elle est là parce que vous me demandez
vous me demandez à la fois une solution
la solution c'est ça c'est revenir à des
choses à des choses normal en face de
toi est-ce que tu as des gens qui ont
déjà été patrons jamais
le problème c'est que j'ai en face de
moi
de j'ai face de moi des G qui lque je
leur dis bouanger mon problème non en
face de moi en face de moi dans
l'administration j'ai des gens qui n'ont
jamais tenu un compte d'exploitation
jamais c'est ça c'est ça la norme leur
norme c'est ça bon et et c'est vrai de
moi industriel c'est vrai du boulanger
c'est vrai du boucher c'est vrai il ne
savent pas ce que c'est que tu RAC donc
deème question tu es en train de me dire
que
selon toi il y a des fonctionnaires
ultra zellés qui appliquent une norme
qui n'existe pas ou qui est supérieure à
la norme décrétée par ou qui ne répond
pas à l'objectif qui répond à l'objectif
de qui a été imaginé pour tu viens voir
dans ta petite guitoune que tu essayes
de faire fonctionner par mon et parau le
mec il te monte un texte de qui qui est
nul et n avenu ou dit vous allez
appliquer ce texte là toi tu le Mones le
texte que tu dois appliquer et tu dis
non tu te j'ai pas envie j'ai pas envie
parce que ça ne répond pas à l'objectif
non non je te parle de texte de loi
texte de loi toi tu tu tu lui montres
ton texte de loi tu dis voilà ta norme
européenne c'est celle-ci tu viens pas
m'emmerder avec ton texte de loi qui
n'existe pas absolument absolument
d'accord exemple exemple plastique le
plastique bashing qu'on a actuellement
en France par rapport à ce qui existe en
Europe en Europe je je pratiquement
toute l'industrie du plastique française
obéit aux normes européennes et mais
elle ne peut pas obéir aux normes
françaises qui sont au-delà de la norme
européenne et donc l'industrie la
plasturgie est en difficulté aujourd'hui
en France par rapport à la plasturgie
allemande ou par rapport à la plasturgie
italienne parce que on a été au-delà et
on a fait quelque chose qui est idiot
idiot par rapport à l'objectif
d'ailleurs si si c'est la norme
française qui est supérieure à la norme
européenne tu peux lui dire écoute ici
on est en Europe tu norme française tu
t'assois dessus alors alors il faut
qu'il y ait il faut qu'il y ait une
il faut qu'il y ait une directive
il y a deux il y a deux palier il y a
quelque chose qui est une norme
européenne et puis à un moment il y a
l'Europe qui dit et bien c'est ça la la
loi européenne et vous devez faire tous
pareil mais mais il y a deux paliers et
nous sommes aujourd'hui pour la plus
grande partie de la placeurgie nous
sommes encore au premier palier
c'est-àdire que il y a un un palier on a
dit voilà ce qu'il faudrait faire les
Français disent non non ça c'est pas
suffisant faut faire au-delà donc c'est
la la loi qui s'applique et et on en
vient contrairement à ce qu'on raconte a
supplié que la norme européenne arrive
pour nous permettre d'être comme les
autres européens pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir résister c'est une his de fou
non mais si le droit européen euh est
prévalent sur le droit français ça
dépend ça dépend quel est le palier qui
a c'estàd il y a un on va se mettre dans
dans la c'est pas une directive ça
s'applique pas si c'est pas une
directive ça s'applique pas bon c'est
une directive d'accord si c'est une
directive ça s'applique c'est bon alors
mais ils attaquent la directive là
actuellement les Français attaquent les
directiv je vais prendre un exemple par
je prendre un exemple je prendre un
exemple sur le plastique unique sur le
plastique à usage unique on dit le
plastique unique c'est pas bon on enlève
le plastique à unique en France tu sais
est-ce que tu sais les répercussions que
ça peut avoir le plastique à usage
unique ça se retrouve dans les boyaux
non pas du tout ça ça se recycle ça se
recycle ça se recycle et on est en train
d'installer du recyclage et nous devons
et nous devons et nous devons
actuellement dans la placeururgie
française comme la la plururgie
française on doit intégrer du plastique
du plastique du plastique ça ser à 100 %
mais on doit intégrer dans le ce qu'on
fait au moins 60 % de plastique recyclé
or nous n'avons plus de plastique
recyclé puisque nous n'avons plus de
production de plastique unique à usage
unique donc on va chercher en Allemagne
en Italie ou en Suisse c'est ça c'est ça
et ça c'est complètement stupide du
point de vue écologique c'est stupide
donc il suffit de de se baisser pour
comprendre que c'est absurde c'estàdire
qu'on est en train de faire une usine au
Havre aujourd'hui ou qui doit recycler
un plastique qu' on ne fait plus en
France alors je je heureusement l'Europe
va venir à notre secours peut-être dans
2 ou 3 ans et on va pouvoir le faire je
veux en venir à à ma 2uxème idée qui
peut-être peut se transformer en
question quand tu as un mec qui vient de
voir dans ton usine et qui dit écoute tu
appppliques pas la bonne directive tu
appppliques pas le bon la bonne
réglementation et toi je suis dit si si
moi j'ai consulté mes avocats
la réglementation que je dois appliquer
pour mon usine qui se trouve telle date
telle jour telle latitude et ainsi de
suite c'est telle réglementation je ne
suis pas d'accord l'autre rest campé sur
ses positions qu'est-ce que tu fais en
tant que patron tu lui envoies un bus
entier d'avocat et tu assignes en
justice le mec qui est en train de
perturber ta production le mec qui est
en train de te perturber pour payer tes
tes salariés et tu lui dis toi tu es
médiocre ton service entier de médiocre
je vais vous montrer en place publique
que vous êtes des médiocre et que vous
vous réfugiez derrière le trait de de de
stylo dire que vous êtes util je ré à ta
question si je suis si j'ai si j'ai mes
anciennes fonctions et j'ai 2000 5000
10000 personnes j'en ai au moins un qui
est capable à temps plein de faire ça
ensuite j'ai suffisamment de Frix pour
payer les avocats si jamais j'ai une PME
de 40 personnes la seule solution c'est
fermer c'est fer la boutique je n'ai pas
une personne qui est capable de de
prendre ce dossier en main et à temps
plein et j'ai pas une personne qui est
capable de payer les avocat au prix où
ils sont donc donc tout ça c'est bon
pour la profession d'avocat c'est pas
bon pour l'industrie française c'est
tout est-ce qu'il y a il y a par exemple
des syndicats de patron je fais je fais
mon candide le MDEF on a reçu l'ancien
président d' très sympa le MF tu vas le
voir tu dis écoute moi mon pote je veux
bien bosser je veux bien faire tourner
le pays mais il faut arrêter vos
conneries ou parce que les mecs il sont
chargé de me contrôler ils ont jamais
tenu un sty ils ont j bossé de leur vie
en dehors que derrière un un bureau moi
je suis censé être la force VI je peux
donner la réponsez la réponse c'est
caricature encore c'est pas une
caricature c'est la réponse j'ai posé
cette question il me dit c'est c'est biz
bizarre ça ne vient pas des fédérations
or je suis moi industriel dans cette
fédération et je sais que les
fédérations sont au courant du fait que
je Râ sur un nombre de points je suis
pas le seul puisque nous rallons tous ça
remonte pas d'accord et et vous vous
donc et donc et donc mon problème
aujourd'hui c'est de dire est-ce que
lorsque le MDEF dit voilà j'ai envie de
faire c et ça est-ce qu'il nous
représente ou pas et c'est pour ça que
je suis aujourd'hui dans un mouvement
patronal adj qui s'appelle éthique parce
que je ne me sens pas représenté par le
MDEF le MF dit voilà ce qu'il faut faire
sur la loi x voilà ce qu'il faut faire
sur le temp je regarde ça je dis en quoi
est-ce que moi ça me concerne ça me
concerne en principe puisque en principe
le MF me représente mais je me considère
pas représenté par le MF ton ton
mouvement éthique là c'est quoi c'est
une petite carmess entreamis en Bretagne
c'est 500 c'est c'est c'est c'est 500
c'est de l'ordre de 500 entreprises et
c'est une une quinzaine de fédération
d'entreprise donc vousêes pas capable de
faire un pot commun pour un chef
d'entreprise qui se fait emmerder et
faire remonter un service qui vous a non
mais non mais non parce que parce que
parce que ça c'est du bénévola c'est
c'est du quasi bénévola parce que c'est
des cotisations relativement FAI c'est
des AC entreprises alors que alors
c'est c'est c'est 500 balles 1000 balles
ça ça fait un quart d'heure d'avocat
donc c'est c'est c'est non mais c'est
c'est c'est on n'est pas dans l'ordre de
grandeur or ceux qui sont financés au
titre de la de du
de la parité c'est ce sont les syndicat
ouvrier et le BDF et le CEPME et l'UDP
c'est c'est tout point donc c'est c'est
ça qui ont les cotisations correspond
les cotisations de l'État qui leur
permet de vivre mais mais si jamais tu
n'es pas tu ne s pas présenté qu'est-ce
que tu peux faire moi je paye
effectivement au titre de de mon
activité de mécanique métallurgie je
paye une cotisation à l'UMM cette
cotisation est reversé pour parti au
MDEF et et et moi j'ai pas VO au
chapitre c'est pas mon problème
circulaire rien à voir alors je prends
sur la figure bah voilà nous on a on a
négocié ça avec les syndicats vous avz
négocié où quand comment qu'est-ce que
est-ce que je le sais moi je sais pas je
rien on a fait ça avec
j'ai appris tout récemment que la
position du MDEF vis-à-vis de la loi
immigration c'était de de de dire non
c'est tout ça n'est pas grave il y a pas
de problème mais si y a des problèmes
mais si y a des problèmes moi j'ai des
problèmes il a des problèmes mais c'est
pas c'est mais c'est pas visiblement
c'est pas les vôtres non mais mais bon
alors vous négociez avec les syndicats
peut-être entre vous mais c'est mais
c'est de l'entre soi c'est de l'entre
soi et et donc vous avez quand même 85 %
des entreprises françaises qui ont
l'emploi et qui font de de de
l'industrie qui non'ont pas ne se
sentent pas représentés parce que vous
dites aux uns et aux autres comment on
fait comment on fait que que comment on
fait voilà c'est c'est et c'est ça le
sujet ce que que j'essaie de traiter
avec le mouvement éthique que j'essaie
de traiter avec d'autres d'autres
d'autres cercles qui permettent de de
d'ouvrir le jeu je vais actuellement
dans des dans dans des régions où on me
dit voilà on a fait une petite
association avec les entreprises je
Dison très bien vous vous êtes pas MF
non on est pas au MF parce que de toute
façon on a le MF ne représente pas il
dit pas il dit pas ce qu'on pense quel
est votre problème et ce sont les mêmes
problèmes que ceux que j'ai je suis allé
dans une dizaine une quinzaine de
régions en France à chaque fois je suis
accueilli à bras ouvert on me demande de
parler de l'énergie de leur
industrialisation de la manière dont on
peut refaire quelque chose et et et on
me dit qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire ben il faut
essayer de trouver une harmonie entre
l'industrie réelle et l'industrie telle
qu'on telle qu'on telle qu'elle est
présenté on est là avec des des gens qui
parlent de du sexe des anges alors que
nous on est les pieds dans la boue avec
une énergie qui a augmenté de de de 5
fois à certain égard l'énergie vous
rendez compte que c'est que 5 fois c'est
même pas le bénéficiaire me disent
quelqu'un j'ai j'ai un type que je suis
rentré dans une il m'a dit voilà je je
payais 4 et maintenant je pay 7 et c'est
ma par bénéficiaire donc heureusement
j'ai une filielle en Roumanie par
conséquent je gagne un peu d'argent en
Roumanie je peux m'en sortir voilà c'est
ça qui m'a dit j'ai entendu il m'a dit
et ainsi de suite c'est ça c'est ça la
réalité de l'industrie française
aujourd'hui et donc il faut revenir à la
réalité revenir à la réalité c'est il
faut au moins que soit les
administrations soit les organisations
représentatives soit les syndicats soit
il faut qu'il ait quelqu'un qui revienne
à la réalité lorsque les les les les
gens qui sont chez moi entend des
syndicalistes parler de l'industrie des
patrons qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un patron
aujourd'hui un patron si jamais si
jamais il a 40 personnes ben il s'occupe
de tout et puis il essaie de voir si il
peut augmenter les salaires de ses
ouvriers pour que les ouvriers restent
et soient contents et soient heureux
c'est ça son problème et et que on
puisse produire c'est ça son sujet le
sujet n'est pas de faire des
manifestations sur les retraites sur les
machin c'est pas le sujet pas sujet
lorsque j'allais dans mes dans le sujet
c'est survivre quoi qu'il arrive c'est
c'est survivre quoi qu'il arrive et rest
avoir des entreprises qui survivent et
qui peuvent qui puissent se développer
effectivement avec un apport de fond
propre avec un apport de là par exemple
au moment du covid on a dit allez-y
prenez la manne céleste du
de du crédit de garanti par l'État alors
allez-y alors pr garanti par l'État bon
aujourd'hui les gens qui ont pris le le
le crédit garanti par l'État il y en a
50000 aujourd'hui 50000 boîtes
industrielles 50000 c'est pas énorme
c'est énorme hein 50000 he c'est c'est
des ouvriers hein bon et et et on leur
dit un vous avez pas remboursé vous êtes
mal on va vous on va vous vous interdire
et et deux vous avez vous voulez
investir vous pouvez pas investir vous
avez pas tant que vous avez pas euh
remis votre votre argent à la banque sur
le crédit des garanti par l'État ah non
vous vous la banque n'existe plus bon
qu'est-ce qu'ils font qu'est-ce qu'ils
font bah ils viennent voir les les tu
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que j'étais
jeune ils viennent voir les jeunes vous
les jeunes les jeun qu'est-ce que je
fais maintenant tu para vieux dans ta
tête tu es quand même je les jeunes
jeunes les jeunes en disant mais
qu'est-ce que je peux faire maintenant
effectivement il faut trouver une
solution est-ce que euh vous tu peux
réduire ton ton personnel est-ce que tu
peux faire c tu peux faire ça des
solutions à la hache où il faut réduire
le chiffre d'affaires euh essayer de pas
trop faire de ruptures conventionnelles
qui vont enlever le l'argent qui nous
reste et puis revenir à une boîte de 30
personnes il faut la remettre à à 20 ou
à 15 et puis repartir de là et
c'est toute ma vie toute ma vie j'ai
fait c entreprise et tu es en train de
me dire de de de de la moitié en
l'air oui il y a pas beaucoup d'autres
solutions ou alors tu te vends mais
vends à qui mais j'ai pas envie de me
vendre j'ai envie de rester c'est c'est
ça le le le la réalité de française
aujourd'hui c'est ça et tant que nous ne
sommes pas au niveau de cette réalité
tant que les autorités
françaises ne comprennent pas et surtout
les administrations dans quelle réalité
on est tant qu'on continue à rêver avec
les grands trucs qui ont fait on fait de
la batterie la batterie on va l'Europe
de la batterie on va la mettre là et on
va mettre 4 milliards 5 milliards h on
va faire l'hydrogène 7 milliards
dehydrogène en avant et puis on va aller
dans les océans et puis on va aller
chercher des des des trucs dans les
océans et on va faire la grande écherie
de l'océan tant qu'on en est là et qu'on
voit et qu'on ne regarde pas la réalité
industrielle et bien et bien on est on
est on le fait de dire on est foutu est
pas inexact alors moi je suis crucifié
de voir que les gens ne veulent toujours
pas regarder la réalité alors c'est vrai
des des autorités c'est vrai des des
administrations et c'est vrai des médias
d'une façon générale pour ça je suis
content de venir parler avec vous parce
que quand quand je parle de ça mais de
vous parlez c'est pas ce qu' c'est il
est marqué il est marqué dans le journal
que le le le prix de l'énergie est en
train de diminuer ben aller voir sur le
terrain les gens qui ont des contrats
sur 2 3 ans et qui ont un contrat à 250
à 300 € le mgawh vous allez leur dire
que le l'électricité baisse où où est-ce
qu'elle baisse à il y a des gens comme
ça oui il y a des gens comme ça bien sûr
c'est la majorité d'ailleurs parce
qu'ils ont passé des contrats et
pourquoi ils ont passé des contrats
parce que vous le AZ demandé de passer
des contrats c'est en fin de l'année on
a dit si jamais vous passez pas de
contrat vous n'aurez plus élericité le
1er janvier alors comment on fait et
après vous leur dites ben non c'est
quand même un dommage que vous soyez pas
en spot et alors que pourquoi vous nêtes
pas en spot en spot vous auriez seriez
mieuxou
en spot c'est-à-dire au jour le jour au
jour le jour j'ai passé un contrat parce
qu'on m'a demandé de passer un contrat
pour avoir l'ricité c'est ça la réalité
de mon job effectivement maintenant ça
prend l'essentiel de ma marge comment je
survis on parle de l'électricité
on a vu EDF encore faire des étincelles
essayer de nous sortir de la mouise avec
notre parc de réacteur qui était un
petit peu cludiicant donc là ils sont
bien dépêchés ils ont travaillé comme
des dingues pour nous remettre un parc
nucléaire
dans une forme un peu plus olympiques
il devrait y avoir des des médailles
chez EDF des augmentations de salaire
des promotions ils sont vraiment tion
aussi sont à chercher un peu partout
parce qu'il y a des sous-traitants il a
pas que il y a pas que les il faut voir
le travail de l'ensemble des
sous-traitants d'électricité à
l'intérieur de de de de ça il y a des
donneurs d'ordre certes mais qui ont été
dans certains cas bon et dans certains
cas moins bon mais il y a surtout énorme
une industrie électro
électronique et électrique parce que
l'électricité électronique sont souvent
les courant faible et courant fort sont
présents dans ce truc là qui est
absolument ordinaire ils ont fait fait
du boulot ils ont fait du boulot pour
arriver à à ce que nous nous puissions
avoir les réacteurs et les terraw qu'il
nous faut mais mais mais mais le
problème c'est que maintenant il faut
savoir vers où on va alors ça c'est la
vraie question ver on va est-ce que vous
sentez vous en tant que patron en tant
que chef d'entreprise en tant que
entrepreneur
qu'il y a une tête en haut du poulet qui
nous dirige où est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que on se retrouve avec
une envolée de de poulet sans tête qui
court un peu partout et on sait pas où
on va on sait pas le but oui pour sair
pour savoir le but il faut avoir ensuite
de la vision ou il faut avoir une bonne
situation mettre l'information dans son
bon contexte avoir de bons capteurs pour
nous donner la bonne météo à l'heure
actuelle on en est où Nicolas loï en
tant que prospective de cap d'objectif
est-ce qu'on n pas en train d'avoir une
administration un gouvernement quelques
syndicat de sachant pas trop où ils vont
faire simplement des petites rustines à
gauche on colmate un peu à droite des
petits CHS des petits chèqu des petits
chè ça on un chè alors chèque maintenant
chèque pour les chaussettes vous avez vu
chaussettes pour les chaussettes si
jamais vous avez chaussettes il faut
garder les chaussettes il faut les
repriser et vous avez un chèque pour les
chaussettes mag c'est magnifique ça les
trous dans les chaussette ça
effectivement c'est un sujet c'est un
sujet absolument régalien qui est du
niveau de l'État mais le problème que
nous avons c'est combien de terraw nous
nous nous devons nous devons avoir et et
comment ces terraw on va les avoir c'est
ça c'est un sujet je vais laisser un peu
Nicolas parce que
il il a envie parler il a envie de
parler un peu de ça non mais terw en
dette vous avez jamais essayé de
convertir la dette française en terraw
ou en baril de pétrole c'est
extraordinaire crois que la dette
française elle correspond plus ou moins
à la somme de notre de notre déficit
commercial sur l'énergie depuis depuis
qu'on en achète quand on fait les
calculs j'ava fait çaou ou grosso modo
non le le problème c'est qu' ils n'ont
pas encore compris que sans énergie bon
marché il y a pas d'industrie alors je
sais qu'on le répète depuis longtemps et
cetera mais c'est vraiment ça le baba
c'estàd que là on a parlé d'électricité
mais le pour moi le problème de
l'industrie elle a deux énergies il y a
l'électricité mais les panneaux les les
les batteries on les fait pas avec des
panneaux solaires les batteries on les
fait avec du gaz les batteries les
voitur éctriques on les fait avec du gaz
parce que c'est des fours il faut
chauffer les cellules et cetera et du
gaz bah qu'est-ce qui s'est passé sur le
gaz on avait du gaz du gaz bon marché et
et on en a plus c'est assez binaire il y
a un pays qui a envahi un autre oui mais
il y en un pays surtout qui avait du gaz
un peu plus cher qui avait envie de le
vendre c'est quel autre pays ça c'est
c'est un truc de côté de l'Atlantique là
il y a un truc un pays là c'est normal
mais il faut il un petit aigle comme
emblème national non il y a pas de
sanction sur le gaz hein on on a
augmenter nos importations de gaz russe
par bateau il y a aucune sanction sur le
gaz naturel russe on peut en acheter
tant qu'on veut on peut pas acheter de
pétrole on peut pas acheter de diesel on
peut pas acheter de charbon on peut pas
acheter d'engrais sauf les Américains je
crois euh parce que eux ils ont fait une
petite un petit astérisque mais on peut
euh on peut on peut acheter du gaz euh
donc bon très bien c'est compliqué hein
et autut
on achète le gaz russe par l'Azerbaïdjan
si jamais un jour on nous embête ça pas
de problème ouais c'est ce qui se passe
d'ailleurs de toute façon hein petite
come azerbaidjani
il y a pas que il y a pas que les gaz il
y a pas que le pipeline qui passe par
Nordstream on pourrait très bien en
avoir par euh bah il y en a toujours le
le seul pipeline qui continue de
fonctionner très bien c'est Brower Hood
qui passe par par l'Ukraine donc
fraterné cel la fraternité voilà
celui-là il continue à fonctionner on a
coupé celui qui passait par la Pologne
et l'Allemagne ça c'est Poutine qui a
coupé parce qu'il voulait mettre en
marche nstam il reste encore un tuo qui
fonctionne sur nstam d'ailleurs si si on
le voulait un tu sur 4 ou un tu sur 4
donc non le le souci c'est que sans gaz
il y a plus d'industrie et au-delà de ça
c'est que non seulement on n pas de gaz
mais en plus donc aujourd'hui il coûte
deux fois plus plus cher qu'avant et le
avant il coûtait deux fois plus cher
qu'aux États-Unis donc aujourd'hui en
fait on est quatre fois plus cher que
les Américains et c'est ça le problème
et que face aux Américains avant on
était comme ça on on se protégeait face
à la Chine parce que les usines partirra
en Chine mais là notre gros concurrent
c'est les États-Unis qui non seulement
va avoir une électricité moins chè que
la nôtre que ce soit le gaz ou
l'électricité mais en plus met en place
des mesures protectionnistes qui sont
totalement contraires aux règles de
l'OMC qui s'appelle si ça sert à rien
bah qu c'est eu qui le dirige ça serv à
nous tuer à part à part nous tuer ça
servit à pas grand chose c'est vrai tu
ont mis quelque chose dont vous avez
peut-être entendu parler qui s'appelle
inflation reduction Act donc ir a et ce
truc en fait qu'est-ce qu'il dit par
exemple sur les voitures électriques il
dit bah écoutez si ta voiture elle est
fabriquée aux États-Unis je te donne
7500 dollars et sinon elle a le droit à
rien donc ça c'est exactement ce que tu
peux pas faire dans les règles de l'OMC
puisque les seuls la seule façon de
faire la discrimination entre pays c'est
soit par rapport au droit de l'homme
soit par rapport à l'environnement et
donc ils sont en train d'absorber donc
toutes les usines là qu'on voulait
monter en Europe le fameux Airbus de la
batterie qui est en train de se
transformer en Boeing de la batterie
parce que les les usines se barre Tesla
devait faire une giga usugine à Berlin
il avait commandé toutes les toutes les
machines outil et cetera il a tout
envoyé au Texas et donc ça c'est ça
c'est terrible parce que nous on est le
nain européen coincé entre les
États-Unis et la Chine de l'autre côté
et en plus notre seule chance d'exister
c'était d'avoir accès aux matières
premières de la Russie et ça c'est
terminé on y aura plus accès et le temps
qu'on redevienne peut-être
éventuellement un jour amis avec les
Russes ils auront tout réinjecté vers
les les Chinois donc ils auront
construit leur pipeline et on Nura plus
rien
triste réalité bon vous avez pas des
bonnes nouvelles les gars parce que ça
non mais c'est alors comment alors le du
point de vue géopolitique on voit bien
les difficultés par conséquent quand on
a des difficultés on les regarde et on
dit comment on s'en sort et c'est ça qui
qui m'intéresse et comment on s'en sort
la vieille école comme ça maintenant
c'est ça qui m'intéresse fut un numéro
vert petit numéro vert allô euh non mais
si on fait pas un bon diagnostic moi sur
si on veut produire en France il y a
trois conditions on a parlé avec depuis
le début un peu avec le la première
question la première condition c'est
énergie bon marché donc et électricité
on a parlé peut-être qu'en 2026 ça va
aller mieux mais 2026 c'est pas tout de
suite on a encore 2 2 ans on a 2 ans on
crève
c'est ce que je dis à chaque fois que je
vois quelqu'un de l'administration je
dis mais dans 2 ans on r gratis ok 2 ans
comment on fait tous les industriels
tous les industriels disent on crève
vous les faites laisser crever pendant 2
ans et alors après vous allez refaire
quelque chose laisser prenez d'abord les
industries telles qu'elles existent
aujourd'hui et essayez de voir comment
elles peuvent être conservé alors c'est
vrai l'ustrie du plastique c'est vrai la
mécanique métallurgie c'est vrai de de
toutes de toutes les industries
d'aujourd'hui elles sont elles sont en
train de de de crever de un petit détail
un petit détail que je voudrais vous
poser comme question tu me dis que dans
2 ans tuasas un nombre de boîtes
incalculable qui va claquer
elles vont peut-être se faire acheter
avant oui par des puissances étrangères
oui mais on sait bien on sait bien
comment ça fait à chaque fois c'est dire
qu'on rachète on rachète quelque chose
qui marche qui marche ou qui mar
technique don on on on suce l'ensemble
de la substance et pu on fabrique
ailleurs à un moment puisque les
conditions dans lesquelles nous
fabriquons qui sont plus chers pour les
raisons que j'ai indiqué c'est vrai
aussi pour les gens qui achètent juste
une question les gens qui laissent faire
ça un jour ou l'autre ils vont en prison
ou pas les gens qui laissent faire ça
c'est-à-dire qui laissent la substance
vive française se faire siphonner par
l'extérieur sontud
fa dire qu'il a un observateur qui
regarde ça quel est l'observateur qui
pourrait regarder ça si jamais vous
considérez que la justice française est
capable de regarder ça
toi tu es dur mais non mais non mais non
en quoi en quoi est-ce que extérieur
laissez laissez faire est-ce que vous
avez une justice industrielle non vous
avez une justice essay se faire
dépouiller la France ça ressemble un
petit peu comment l'exunion soviétique
s'est fait dépouiller à lesffondrement
de soviétique quand même non mais c'est
c'est les règ est-ce qu'il y a des gens
qui se font taper
c'est les règles du jeu c'est les r quel
jeu mais c'est les règles du jeu et
quand vous avez un président qui qui
fait passer l'intérêt de l'Europe devant
de la France ben c'est ce qui se passe
c'est aussi simple que ça le problème
c'est qu'on a plus personne qui
défendent les intérêts de lorsque
lorsque lorsque vous vous vous avez
comme euh comme objectif l'attractivité
de la France et chose France qu'est-ce
que vous faites vous demandez à des
étrangers de venir acheter en France ce
qu'il y a et vous voulez me dire que si
jamais des gens achètent et font des
bêtises n'est-ce pas ils vont être puni
non au contraire on on leur demande de
venir et d'acheter donc je vois pas
pourquoi ils seraiit puni ils font ce
qui ils font ce qu'on leur demande on
leur dit venez en France alors j'avais
regardé par exemple au moment du covid
j'avais regardé comment les les gens
avait qui avait été aidé pour subsister
au moment du covid je vais regarder ça
puis j'avis regardé dans l'industrie
automobile qui a été aidé et donc il y
avait un grand document et j'ai pris
capitaux français capitaux étranger
capitaux français capitaux étranger je
suis arrivé à 50 % de de l'industrie
aidée était capitaux français 50 %
deindustrie étrangère ok ensuite j'ai
regardé le matériel j'aié le matériel et
j'ai vu 80 % de l'ensemble du matériel
était euh acheté à l'étranger bon alors
j'ai dit bon par exemple moi quand quand
j'achète du matériel je j'hésite entre
ce que du matériel neuf ou du matériel
usager que je remets en en selle et le
matériel usagéasion c'est c'est ce que
j'appelle rétrofit les gens rétrophy bon
et quand je prends du matériel rétrophy
grossièrement j'arrive à peu près à la
moitié je lui installe un peu de robot
un peu de de de numérique un peu de bon
finalement je m'en tire à peu près à la
moitié mais là j'ai pas de subvention
donc les gens qui achètent du matériel
neuf ils arrivent à recevoir plus
d'argent que moi qui a pris du rétrofit
du matériel ancien et qui essayie de
faire je dis aux gens est-ce que vous
pouvez pas mettre dans votre politique
de subvention au moment du covid le fait
de faire du rétrofit c'est pas idiot ah
non monsieur c'est pas du tout c'est pas
la règle c'est c'est ça que que je que
je quel est l'objectif l'objectif c'est
de réindustrialer le pays est-ce qu'on
peut réindustrialiser le pays avec du
matériel ancien oui est-ce que on peut
le mettre au bout du jour avec de la
robotisation l'automatisation et
numérique la réponse est oui est-ce que
c'est un objectif ah non c'est pas un
objectif l'objectif c'est d'aller
acheter du matériel chinois du matériel
japonais dans ce CASL il y a rien à
faire Nicolas je crois qu'il nous manque
des ingénieurs c'est tout quoi que tu me
direz la première ministre a fait
Polytechnique mais non le don je voulais
revenir sur tout à l'heure sur comment
on produit en France pour essayer de
trouver des solutions donc la première
c'est l'énergie bon l'électricité
peut-être dans 2 ans et demi
le gaz non non non non non non 2 an et
demi pour ceux qui se seront réunis en
groupe pour pouvoir négocier leur prix
c'est ça qui est marqué dans dans le
journal c'est ça qui est marqué journal
Le Petit qui est tout seul il est foutu
de toute façon lui il est cuit bon
maintenant si jamais il se réunit avec
d'autres et qu'il a une marge de
négociation il va pouvoir avir anc lo là
voà quoi je
non donc euh deuxième chose les normes
on est quand même le seul pays on en a
parlé mais on s'applique des normes donc
plus sévères que les normes européennes
et que normes qu'on applique jamais à
nos importation donc c'est ça qui est
terrible tu parlais de l'histoire de la
ton histoire de la chips par exemple là
où finalement enfin ça marche pour
l'agriculture ça marche ces produits
c'estd en BR en Bran on peut plus on
peut plus faire prendre de Patat parce
que les patates il y avait un
intesticide qu'prenait et on avait le
pouvoir on pouvait faire la culure de
patates et donc on avait des patates et
on avait des chips correspondante et un
chips les mec les types me disent les
Typs me disent non il y a plus
d'insecticide al ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'on a plus de patate pour
faire les chips trs bien qu'est-ce que
vous faites on ferme l'usine voilà c'est
c'est c'est complètement fou mais c'est
la réalité c'est pour ça que quand on
parle de produire en France interdit par
qui il y a peut-être quand même
quelqu'un qui réfléchit au problème oui
parce que bon des fois il y a des
substances qu'on peut mettre que on se
rend compte que 20 ans plus tard que ça
se termine comme polluant et et et ce
polluant il est pas éliminable et que ça
reste dans les pourquoi pourquoi on est
les seuls la Bretagne ils ont quand même
pourquoi on serait les seuls pourquoi on
serait les seuls on est français on doit
montrer l'exemple c'est ça voilà et ben
voilà et bien l'exemple c'est l'exemple
de la la norme sur les normes on fait
les normes européenne oui et ce sera
très bien sur le nucléaire sur
l'industrie
arrêtons de vouloir laver plus blanc que
blanc on fait lesénmes européenne c'est
déjà les plus élevés du monde ça évite
d'avoir des des rivières rouges jaunes
et toutes les couleurs c'est déjà très
bien je suis d'accord mais en fait en
France on est un pays où on fait du Zè
on a fait du zel comme d'ailleurs sur le
nucléaire on a fait du zel où on a
décidé du jour au lendemain parce qu'on
a découvert un problème de firemer 10
réacteurs du jour au lendemain c'est ça
qui qui a envoyé un maximum d'entreprise
c'est ça qui a fait exploser les prix
l'leectricité je me fais l'avocat du
diable
le principe de précaution de temps en
temps c'est pas mal maiss oui mais après
c'est le poisson est dans la dose c'est
pas c'est pas c'est pas une précaution
ça c'est c'est pas une précaution ça
c'est une stupidité faut faut changer
faut changer les noms qu'one qu'on
prenne une précaution parce que il y a
un danger mais que on est on sait qu'on
a pas de danger mais on a envie de dire
oh là là il faut faire peur il faut
faire peur et qu'on invente un danger
pour prendre une précaution ça c'est
c'est embêtant donc c'est là c'est là la
limite de l'exer et aujourd'hui le
principe de précaution qui était pas
forcément idiot est transformé par dès
qu'il y a quelqu'un qui parle sur un
danger potentiel on dit on arrête non ça
c'est pas possible et là en l'occurrence
il y avait réacteur qui était pareil il
y en avait un qui avait un problème on
savait que ce problème existait depuis
une dizaine d'années c'est quoi la
source quoi c'est quoi la source de ça
on savait depuis 10 ans on savait depuis
10 ans j'étais dans les endroits où il
fallait et je peux vous vous dire qu'on
savait depuis 10 ans qu'on savait qu'il
y avait un problème de corrosion sous
contat on Savit depuis début de toute
façonbuton
on avait on avait on avait il y avait il
y avait un tuyau comme ça puis un tuyau
qui était là et puis il fallait le
mettre là on savait qu'on avait fait la
contrainte et qu'on avait fait la
soudure et que c'est c'était embêtant
alors on surveillait les soudures qui
qui avaient été faites sous contrainte
c'est facile hein bon et puis on
observait qu'il y avait des petits des
petits machins sur une des centrales bon
très bien alors pe quand même he regardé
on l'a regardé on l'a regardé c'est 3 mm
3 mm puis au bout de 10 ans tu toujours
3 mm et puis à un moment il a dit oh là
là il y en a h pareil si toutes sont
pareil on arrête tout c'est pas la
précaution ça c'est la stupidité et on a
fait quelque chose de stupide voilà
c'est ça qui c'est ça où ça va pas hein
c'estàd que quel est l'objectif
l'objectif c'est d'assurer la sécurité
des centrales d'accord en quoi est-ce
que la corison sous contrainte était un
endroit où il y avait un problème de
sécurité n part c'était le réseau
secondaire le réseau où il y a pas de où
il y a pas de danger alors c'est
embêtant mais on peut surveiller et on
peut faire un dispositif de surveillance
et et ça on est incapable de faire
c'està dire que les la la capacité à
considérer qu'il y a une peur et que il
faut que ça va être un un truc
épouvantable et qu'il faut arrêter tout
cette C cette contrainte est une
contrainte très française au vous avez
des bonnes nouvelles mais bien sûr la
bonne nouvelle la bonne nouvelle c'est
que si jamais on revient à la réalité et
si jamais on dit effectivement nous
avons une industrie qui existe encore
aujourd'hui et nous avons envie de la
maintenir plutôt que de parler de
réindustrialisation hypothétique
fantastique et nous avons la possibilité
de le faire nous avons des gens bien
nous avons des gens qui sont qui qui
nous avons nous avons des compétences
extraordinaires nous avons réussi à
avoir avec les alternances que qui ont
été réalisés ces ces derniers temps qui
c'est une bonne nouvelle nous avons des
gens compétents qui ont envie de des
entreprises lorsqu'avec le M éthique on
fait j'aime ma boîte on s'aperçoit que
sur les sondage les gens qui sont dans
l'industrie disent à 75 % oui j'aime ma
boîte et j'aienvie qu' persiste j'aime
ma boîte non c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est c'est donc on voit qu'il y a une
un engagement fort pour l'industrie on a
des gens compétents on est forme donc il
suffit simplement de se baisser pour
dire comment est-ce qu'on persévère dans
ce dans dans cette dans cette action et
comment on arrive à éviter les écueils
de la désindustrialisation qui se
poursuit aujourd'hui et c'est et ça
c'est facile c'est facile il suffit
d'avoir une une administration
bienveillante qui interprète
correctement les textes et qui considère
que des dérogations sont possibles si
jamais vous si jamais vous arrivez à
obtenir ça après on est tranquille sur
ma ma fonderie j'ai je dis ben voilà
j'ai une dérogation parce que je mets
jamais d'eau dans dans truc c'est
impossible parce que j'explose vous é
pas d'eau il y a pas de raison d'avoir
une réglementation sur l'eau
d'extinction des feux puisque vous aurez
jamais VO c'est tout je demande
simplement ça si je vais de l'autre côté
de la frontière en en puisque je suis pr
près de la Suisse c'est ce qui est fait
les Suisses dis ça mais non c'est sur
cette ce type de fonderie c'est pas la
peine on met jamais d'eau donc c'est pas
la peine de faire c réglementation
Nicolas quand tu entends ce vieux Doig
argenté à ta droite
pester sur ce qui se passe toi en tant
que jeune patron
jeune entrepreneur jeune chef
d'entreprise
produisant français
fait comment pour survivre bah en fait
c'est très simple on déménage en Tunisie
c'est ça non ce qui est très simple
c'est qu'on en fait on l'Europe depuis
toujours cherche à imiter s'inspirer de
son grand frère américain bah on fait
comme eux point barre on fait comme les
États-Unis qu'est-ce qu'il font les
États-Unis exemple on a les mêmes
centrale nucléaire que les Américains
puisque on a une licence au départ qui
est une licence westing house quand il
quand ils font la révision des centrales
tous les 10 ans pour prolonger la durée
de vie le cahier des charges la norme
c'est que la centrale respecte le cahier
des charges les normes lors de sa
construction et les centrales
américaines les réacteurs qui sont les
mêmes réacteurs qu'on a chez nous ils
durent jusqu'à 80 ans d'accord
ça c'est un petit peu ce qui se passe
quand vous faites le contrôle toctique
de votre voiture vous regardez voilà
qu'est-ce qu'elle pollue euh
en France en France la centrale qu'on a
conduit construit il y a 40 ans il faut
qu'elle respecte la norme de l'pr
d'accord donc ça veut dire je prends ma
vieille voiture qui a 10 ans écoute faut
que tu fasses les mêmes émissions qu'une
voiture électrique ah bah oui mais c'est
compliqué ah B non mais tu fais comme la
voiture électrique et donc aujourd'hui
forcément ça va être quand même très
compliqué d'emmener notre parc de
réacteur à 80 années si on leur dit bah
qu' tu dois respecter les normes de le
Pr qui intègre la chute d'un avion la
chute d'un avion Fukushima tchernoby et
cetera et cetera donc première chose sur
les normes on s'aligne sur les
Américains
on leur acheté les centrales on s'aligne
sur les Américains est-ce qu'il y a des
accidents aux ÉtatsUnis priori non
deuxièmement dans chaque voiture que
vous achetez aux États-Unis il y a
marqué où est-ce que la voiture est
fabriquée où est-ce que la voiture est
fabriqué où est-ce qu'elle assemblé sur
sur l'étiquette ça c'est interdit en
Europe ça c'est interdit pas de
discrimination on marque quand le mec va
s'acheter sa voiture regardez ça
pourraiter par exemple Bruno Le Maire
quand il s'est acheté sa Bruno Le Maire
c'est qui br de la mer il s'est acheté
c'est un jeune entrepreneur mais qui
créit des très bon qui créit des bons
bouquins c'est un écrivain un écrivain
incompris encore BR le ma quand il s'est
acheté sa 208 électrique avec laquelle
il s'affiche fièrement sur les réseaux
sociaux il y avait pas l'étiquette pour
marqué où c'était fabriqué il savait pas
que c'était fabriqué à Bratislava en
Slovaquie sinon il ferait peut-être
moins le malin pour dire regardez
acheter français et donc aujourd'hui
rien que pour les gens s'ils veulent
acheter une Clio ils disent ah c'est
génial c'est français elle est fabriqué
en Turquie ta voiture j'achète une ah
ben elle est fabriqué au Maroc si avait
marqué l'endroit où elle est fabriqué
rien de savoir où elle est fabriqué
première chose donc ça deuxième chose
pas très compliquée à faire d'ailleurs
on le fait en Europe sur les fruits et
les légumes hein on met le lieu de
fabrication ben on pourrait le faire sur
ça marche pour aussi le textile ça
marche pour tout que les gens et
puissent avoir l'information parce que
si les gens vont payer 5 10 20 % plus
cher il faut qu'ils sacheent pourquoi si
on leur donne pas l'information ben
c'est parce que c'est fabriqué en France
c'est plus compliqué donc deuxème idée
tr idée on assume comm Donald Trump je
fa je fais je fais Joe Biden il a mis en
place dont Donald Trump prévait qu'il
vous donne de l'argent si c'est fabriqué
aux États-Unis fait pareil moi prenons
l'exemple de la voiture électrique
pendant des années l'an dernier on a
donné 500 millions d'euros à la Chine on
leur a donné 500 million d'euros pour
qu'il fabrique des batteries parce que
le bonus la subvention c'est ça c'est
bah 6000 € fois on multiplie par le
nombre de voitures 80 % des batteries
sont fabriquées en Chine donc on
subventionne les Chinois bah c'est
facile là l'ADEM a monté une usine à gaz
alors ça va dans le bon sens moi je
l'avais proposé avec France stratégie il
y a 4 ans d'arrêter de conditionner les
aides à l'achat et une sorte de de
performance environnementale et cetera
donc la dame a fait un truc avec SEP
critères pour réussir à sortir les
véhicules électriques fabriqués en Chine
au charbon mais pas fabriqués en Pologne
au charbon donc ça c'est pas forcément
évident par contre les voitures
fabriquées en France mais avec une
batterie chinoise elles vont pas avoir
la subvention donc ça c'est un peu
dommage on simplifie madeine France pas
mine France mine France tu as la
subvention pas mine France tu as pas
subvention c'est contraire au trait Rome
très bien on en discute et puis on voit
ce qu'on peut faire on en discute mais
les gens en France on est comme ça
toujours à dire oui mais c'est contrair
à non on discute on discute on négocie
on a un rapport de force on l'a eu par
exemple là sur l'électricité les on
voulait avoir des contrats qui prenaient
en compte notre nucléaire existant les
Allemands le voulaient pas ben on a
discuté on a eu un rapport de force et
effectivement on a gagné C arbitrage
mais on a pas gagné souvent des
arbitrages au niveau européen ben là il
faut en gagner il faut en gagner de plus
en plus et si on n pas capable de faire
ça on peut faire une autre chose qu'on a
le droit de faire ça c'est quelque chose
dont j'avais discuté avec avec Yv G qui
la pororte non pas quelqu non fiscalité
kilométrique parce qu'en fait on se dit
le on imagine bien que le monde du futur
c'est on va essayer de raccourcir les
distances on va essayer de rapprocher le
consommateur ou le producteur du
consommateur donc le bon le le bon
critère le la bonne chose que Reger
c'est la distance la distance c'est les
kilomètres bon ben qu'est-ce qu'on fait
on pourrait faire très facilement
quelque chose abaisser on a le droit en
Europe de toucher au taux de TVA normal
entre 15 et 25 ça on a le droit de faire
sans sortir de l'Europe donc là on est à
20 on descend à 15 15 % de TVA et sur
ces 15 % de TVA on rajoute un élément de
fiscalité kilométrique qui n'est pas de
la TVA que la fiscalité c'est une
prérogative des États-membres et cette
fiscalité kilométrique elle est indexée
sur la distance parcourue par l'objet et
ça les distances on les connaît avant
livraison voilà de de l'usine
d'assemblage au point de livraison au
port et cetera euh donc moins moins de
1000 km z0ro ça fait 15 % de TVA pour
les produits fabriqués en France et puis
après euh en Europe ou 3000 km 5 % 3000
5000 10 % 5000 machin 15 % vous pouvez
faire pareil en disant Union européenne
5 % proche Europe donc Turquie Maghreb
10 % et puis après États-Unis Chine 15 %
et vous ça c'est un truc qu'on peut
mettre en place qu'on a droit faire on a
pas besoin de sortir de l'Europe on
revient on revient à quel est l'objectif
attel objectif il revient il dit il dit
l'objectif c'est
c'est ça non j'adère à son
proposobjectif
ça quand j'en ai parlé alors je suis
allé voir j'ai eu des échanges avec un
conseiller de Bruneau le maire
un conseil de BR le et donc mais donc
quand on dit ça c'est ça qu'il faut
faire et ben non c'est contraire à l'UR
non mais attendez à un moment donné si
le prisme de lecture c'est c'est quoi
l'objectif c'est quand même l'intérêt de
la France est-ce que l'intérêt est-ce
que notre objectif c'est de
réindustrialiser l'Europe ou de
réindustrialiser la France c'est ça le
problème parce que là en fait on est en
train de faire des règles pour
réindustrialiser l'Europe mais la
désindustrialisation de la France depuis
20 ans c'est pas que vers la Chine c'est
intrauropéen c'est de partir en Europe
de l'Est sur l'automobile on ferme 12
usines d'assemblage en Europe de l'Ouest
on en ouvre 11 en Europe de l'Est c'est
pas la Chine notre la Chine c'est not
problème maintenant avec les voitures
électriqu mais avant c'est c'est tous
les pays d'Europe de l'Est c'est les
pays à bacoup c'est Pologne Roumanie
Slovaquie Hongrie et cetera et c'est
c'est là que tout est parti c'est là que
l'électrominag est parti c'est là que le
les pneus sont partis tout est parti
dans ces pays-là et donc en fait si on
met pas des mesures intraeuropéennes moi
je me suis en 2000 en 2012 2013 je suis
aller voir le cabinet d'Arnaud mtebourg
euh donc ministre de l'Économie ministre
de du redressement productif je croisis
pas si
et donc je suis all voir je leur dis
voilà il y a deux choses à faire on met
une taxe carbone aux frontières de la
France taxe carbone indexée sur le
contenu carbone de l'électricité parce
qu'on a l'électricité la plus décarbonée
au monde premièrement sur tous les
objets deuxièmement
parce que mon mon sujet c'est les
voitures on met un bonus sur le poids
des voitures légères on encourage les
voitures légères on pénalise les
voitures lourdes on avait 9 milliards
d'euros de déficit commercial avec
l'Allemagne sur l'automobile et c'est du
jour au lendemain avec un bonus malus il
y il y a plus de déficit c'est terminé
parce que là qu'est-ce qui se passe on
leur achète beaucoup de voitures lourdes
et on leur vend très peu de voitures
légères mettez ça en place c'est terminé
le lendemain et donc j'ai dit ça et
qu'est-ce qu'elle m'a dit elle dit
Monsieur Méan c'est très bien vos idées
mais al déjà elle m'a dit c'est pas
l'agenda du ministrre je fais ah ben ça
c'est intéressant parce que je me
demandais bien en 2013 quelle était son
agenda il non mais vous comprenez faut
surtout pas se fâcher avec les Allemands
je comment ça faut pas se fâcherement
mais ça c le cabinet de Montebourg ouais
on va appeler monbourg tout de
suite'est- histoire 201 et donc mais
d'ailleurs j'ai eu l'occasion d'en
parler avec lui non et donc le problème
c'est que tant qu'on a pas et là on
commence à un peu la voir des tant qu'on
on pas ce bras de F avec l'Allemagne qui
permet de rééquilibrer l'Europe dans
notre intérêt parce que là l'Allemagne
est l'Europe est orienté que dans les
intérêts des allemandhomme malade de
l'Europe l'Allemagne l'homme malade de
l'Europe non c'est la locomotive sauf
que la locomotive on vient de lui couper
le carburant donc elle va emmener toute
l'Europe avec elle il y a l'Allemagne
c'est la locomotive c'est elle qui fait
notre excédent commercial en vendant des
bagnoles aux États-Unis et des
machinesoutil en en Chine s'il te plaît
l'Allemagne onemne
l'Allemagne malheureusement
si on les perd tout le monde part
partira pas tout seul les Allemands
c'est on est on a déjà on a déjà des
problèmes avec ce que nous avons fait
avec les sanctions contre la Russie si
jamais maintenant l'Allemagne a des
difficultés n on va plonger encore plus
vite hein donc c'est c'est c'est pas
c'est notre principal partenaire c'est
c'est partenaire c'est le partenaire
essentiel vous avez étudié un petit peu
les fondamentaux de l'Allemagne
récemment ou pas ou si si mais on est
inquiet on est inquiet on est inquiet et
les Allemands sont inquiets et si jamais
et si jamais mes amis allemands me
demande me demande est-ce que si on
rachète la centrale nucléaire qui a été
qui a été fermée en Bavière est-ce que
vous êtes capable de la remettre en
selle ben je comprends parce que
effectivement pour la Bavière le fait
d'avoir de l'électricité chère donc qui
est compensé par des subventions mais
les subv pension jusqu'à quand
vont-elles rester leur pose un problème
de délocalisation le plus rapidement
possible vers les États-Unis cont tenu
du prix de l'électricité tel que l'a
exposé Nicolas donc c'est c'est un vrai
c'est un vrai sujet mais voyez je je
reviens je reviens à son propos pour
reprendre le mien au départ de cet
entretien c'est il faut avoir savoir
quel est l'objectif si l'objectif c'est
l'industrie française et bien on essaie
de faire des choses qui sont conformes
aux intérêts de l'industrie française si
l'objectif n'est pas l'industrie
française et l'industrie c'est de de de
mettre ch France c'est-à-dire de mettre
des les les gens en France pour acheter
l'E française et qui partent avec si ça
c'est l'objectif effectivement
l'objectif est atteint actuellement mais
si l'objectif est bien de que la qu'il
ait une France industrielle et que
l'industrie se développe en France et
bien les les les les suggestions qui
sont faites ous les articles qui sont
faits ici
son cont son productif il y a combien de
patrons au gouvernement zé des mecs des
mecs qu'on fait des boîtes quoi zé si je
crois Oliv grégoard elle dirigeait une
agence de communication non
arrêtez de me faire peur là
pas mais un patron ouvrier
ouv desouv il y a quelques et il y a il
doit y avoir il doit y avoir quelques
patrons alors c'est une bonne question
vous posez c'estàd que est-ce que moi
industriel
je suis depuis longtemps est-ce que j'ai
eu envie de de faire de la politique
d'être ministre la réponse est non donc
je je reconnais que que je je suis mal
placé pour critiquer le fait qu'il y a
pas de patron dans la politique et dans
les ministères puisque moi en tant en
tant que patron j'ai pas eu envie d'être
ministre qu on m'a proposé d'êre
ministre pas ass parce que parce que non
c'est pas une question de paix c'est une
question d'intérêt moi je quand je suis
maître chez moi dans dans les
entreprises que je dirige et je suis
content d'être chez moi d'avoir des
objectifs de répondre aux objectifs là
le l'objectif de la de de de la
politique les conseils interministériels
que j'ai connu les euh les les trucs et
non vous avez pas le droit de faire ça
parce que le sondage est mauvais tout ça
tout ça c'est c'est c'est c'est
insupportable donc et et les patrons qui
ont été qui ont été ministres ont été
très malheureux mon ami Francis Mer qui
vient de décéder il a étit très
malheureux communé d'économie très
malheureux il il dit mais c'est pas
possible de d'être dans des conditions
pareilles pierre drefus dont j'ai été
directeur de cabinet il disait mais moi
quand j'étais chez Renault j'étais
j'étais bien mais qu'est-ce que c'est
cette histoire pourquoi est-ce que les
gens veulent faire des bêtise euh et euh
et et me mettre sur le dos c'est pas
possible c'est il y a il y a une autre
il y a une autre atmosphère alors
comment attirer des gens qui connaissent
l'industrie c'est une autre question
l'industrie dans les ministères et dans
l'administration ça j'en sait rien mais
euh aujourd'hui on est on est au degré
zéro c'est-à-dire que effectivement les
membres des cabin ministériel comme je
dis tout à l'heure n'ont jamais tenu à
con d'explloitation second non non mais
vas-y je te laisse non mais je suis
d'accord avec toi mais je continue donc
c'est compliqué compqué je veux parler
un peu de les les les membres du cabinet
ministérial parce que c'est quelque
chose un sujet qui est cher aussi à à
yvrechet et moi je moi je j'ai passé qui
est anen ancien Aué commissaire euh
commissaire à l'énergie atomique
exactement euh ancien au commissaire
àgie atomique j'ai passé France
stratégie donc j'étais conseiller
scientifique donc j'étais à temps
partiel un ou de jours par semaine et
donc tarif alors pour un jour par
semaine j'ai gagné 150 € par jour donc
600 € par mois voilà c donc quand je me
compare à mins j' à peu près 20 fois
moins cher qu'un consultant de mins
parce que lui c'est plutôt 3000 € par
jour 150 3000 donc conver mais il a des
charges des charges compr oui c'est donc
j'étais pas très loin
je peux pas dire c'est du bénévol parce
qu'on non quand même 150 € par jour
c'est beaucoup tu comprends c'est 20 €
par he€ par he c'est ce que je gagnais
quand je faisais des je crois quand
j'étais en terminal et que jeais des
cours ou quand j'étais cours terminal je
crois gagn 20 € par heure me qui a fait
le MIT c'est quand même pas ch 50 € par
jour ça rembourse pas mon mon prê de
40000 dollars du MIT c'est
mais donc les conseills ministériels en
fait le problème c'est que ces gensl ça
dire quoi mit pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas mit avec l'accent alors
massachaussett mais il est dur c'est
comme les chaussettes de l'archiduchesse
massachuss Institute of Technology
ouais donc le les conseillers
ministériels moi j'en ai rencontré
quelquesuns d'ailleurs j'ai une histoire
quand j'ai proposé j'ai fait on a fait
une note avec France stratégie où je
peux proposer un bonus manus sur le
poids des voitures he parce que par du
consta que les tanks électriques
peut-être que ça va pas sauver la
planète non plus tank électrique les
tanks électriques ouais ou c'est ce
qu'on fait aujourd'huile T et donc moi
je dis B faut mieux faire des petites
voitures à essence que des tanks
électriques et donc c'est pour ça que
j'encourageais à donner 1000 € enfin un
bonus sur le poids y compris voitures
thermiques ce qui rendu compte que les
gens comprenaient pas la logique comment
tu peux donner de l'argent une voiture
thermique tu es le diable ca et donc en
fait j'ai été convoqué j'ai mon truc a
été repris par certains députés et donc
il a eu des amendements déposés dans le
projet de loi des finances je sais plus
si c'était en pour 2020 je crois et et
donc Elisabeth borne a vu ce truc arrivé
c'était la ministre du Transport sur son
bureau mais c'est quoi cette histoire de
bonus malus sur le poids qu'est-ce qui
nous emmerde avec ce trucsl c'est qui
Elisabeth borne et donc une
poltechnicienne et donc elle était donc
premire ministre d'un pays en
sousdéveloppement chronique là comment
ça s'appelle déjà elle a été et donc
elle et donc moi j'ai été j'ai été
convoqué par ses conseillères B tu as
été invité oui invité invité la veille
du passage à l'Assemblée nationale du
projet de loi des finances pour qu'elle
me dise pour discuter ce truc là
qu'elles avaient pas vu passer et donc
j'ai eu deux personnes en face de moi
qui n'étaient pas ingénieur et qui m'ont
expliqué qu'en fait taxer les véhicules
sur le poids c'était complètement
stupide ça n'avait aucun intérêt de
toute façon on mesurer le CO2 et cetera
et donc j'ai eu un réquisitoire pendant
une demi-heure j'ai dis bon ben c'est
bien je pouroi tu as pas été écouté
c'est ça c'est sympa non de de pourquoi
mon idée était stupide de toute façon
donc elles m'ont reçu peut-être par
politesse ou je sais pas quoi et et donc
en fait euh tuas pas eu l'idée de filmer
ça non mais je suis pas sûr d'ailleurs
que j'ai le droit et pu de chez M non Mo
comme ça pour faire avli expliquez à ces
gens mais ça vous pouvez aller chez
Michelin que quand il y a du poids il y
a de l'usure des pneus et a des particul
des particules fines parce que les
Michelin les gens de chez Michelin
parlent beaucoup mais on les écoute pas
il y en a qui parlent beaucoup qui
essayent de conseiller certains chefs
d'État mais on les écoute pas oui mais
disons que il y a des industriels qui
sur l'automobile et qui ne sont pas pas
l'industrie automobile en tant que tel
par qu'on dit voilà il y a de cons
automobile pu il y a des gens qui sont
des sous-traitants automobiles ou qui
sont des composants automobiles et parmi
ceux-l il y en a un qui est quand même
important dans le monde qui est Michelin
et Michelin dit il y a un problème
d'usure des pneus quand il y a trop de
poids et par conséquent il faut regarder
aussi ce problème parce que il y a des
particules fines qui partent et et et et
donc et et ça c'est inaudible c'est ça
ça fait des années que les gens de
Michin disent c'est inaudible ils
n'entendent pas ils n'entendent pas
pourtant il y a eu des gens extrêmement
prestigieux qui sont passés par des des
tas de tas d'endroits et qui étaient
chez Michelin mais non c'est ça ça
n'existe pas et et et le poids est
important alors le poid c'est d'autant
plus drôle que vous avez donc une une
plastique bachine complet or la seule
manière de diminuer le poids quand vous
avez des batteries énormes et que vous
êtes une voiture électrique c'est de
mettre le maximum de plastique partout
parce que plastique c'est léger par
rapport au métal hein même l'aluminium
donc donc donc on dit il faut plus de
plurgie il faut plus de le plastique
c'est mal mais il faut une voiture
électrique et il faut le voiture
électrique avec des batteries qui sont
lourdes et avec des pneus mais les pneus
c'est pas grave ils peuvent en des
particules on s'en fiche simplement oui
effectivement si jamais les les voitures
sont légères ce serait quand même un peu
mieux comme les batteries sont lourdes
on va mettre du plastique mais le
plastique mais fait rien le plastique
c'est mauvais hein le plastique ça va
dans les chez les chez les c moi je
voulais je voulais je voulais juste je
juste sur mon mes petits conseils il
m'en veut pas hein vas-y conseiller
parce que en fait finalement et parce
que je pense que désolé mais c'est là où
ça bloque c'est c'est dans c'est à cet
endroit-là où les où les rapports
remontent vous avez un conseiller qui
souvent a fait
Polytechnique Polytechnique incpétent
harard qui Harvard qui a bossé un peu
dans les services qui a aucune
expérience dans l'entreprise qui va se
retrouver peut-être je sais je sais pas
conseiller industriel du président de la
République sans avoir bossé un jour de
sa vie dans une industrie et en fait ces
gens-là et ces gensl comment ils
réfléchissent ils voient le rapport
première question est-ce que ça peut me
servir dans ma carrière oui ou non si ça
passe oui deuxème question est-ce que ça
peut servir oui ou non à mon ministre
c'est caricatural oui non c'est pas
caricatural troisème question est-ce que
ça peut servir oui ou non l'intérêt de
la France donc il faut leur intérêt
l'intérêt du ministre l'intérêt de la
France qui passe en dernier c'est ça le
problème je suis pas sûr que le dernier
ils arrivent ah benah oui souvent il AR
je pense
démon toi toi tu es possédé par le déb
pas du tout mais pas du tout mais pas du
tout j'ai rencontre mais c'est vrai en
fait si ça va dans l'intérêt non mais
c'est je suis d'accord avec le parce que
si ça va dans l'intérêt est-ce que ça va
dans mon intérêt de moi oui si ça va
dans le ministre oui est-ce que c'est la
France non bah ils le font quand même
oui en fait ils s'en foutent c'est quoi
votre stratégie de contreinfluence face
à ça parce que les patrou il prévoi de
se mettre en grève il prévoit arrêter de
payer la taxe professionnelle il prévoit
quoi il pré
attention
je va je vais répondre je répondre à la
question je répond à la question prière
chose patr actuelr Act ils ont des
mesures proctive qui ressemble à quoi
parce que là je te vois les bras croisés
les jambes croisées je veux bien que tu
pestes dans ton coin avec tes potes en
Bretagne mais un moment il faut être un
petit peu opératif légal les patrons
actuels essa de trouver des solutions à
leur problème et donc ils essaient de
d'innover de trouver des niches où ils
peuvent conserver des marges malgré tout
ce que je peux raconter il sont là IRAM
bon il y a donc ça c'est une minorité
qui disent on y croit encore on y va
cette minorité est active elle est elle
est extraordinaire moi je c'est c'est
mes copains c'est mes copains besogneux
bon la deuxième c'est dire B écoutez bon
moi j'ai 50 ans ou 55 ans j'ai bâti
cette entreprise je vais la vendre et je
vais parer en Suisse parce qu'en plus je
vais me faire savonner par les impôts
ainsi de suite c'est ça je vais la
vendre ok jeis la vendreor
c'estd que Mo je considère que depuis le
le l'augmentation de prix de l'énergie
c'estàd depuis 2 ans le nombre
d'entreprises à vendre de gens qui ne
sont pas encore à l'âge que je considère
être l'âge de la retraite à décuplé donc
il y a 10 fois plus d'entreprises
aujourd'hui à vendre que il y a de ça 3
an avent dans de Bones conditions ça
ressemble pas taay il essai V dans les
meilleures conditions il ESS ils
essayent de mon ils ont c'est leur c'est
leur bébé c'est leur truc ils essaient
la vendre le mieux possible c'est la
raison pour laquelle lorsqu'on dit ch
France ils sont contents parce que si
jamais il y a un étranger dans le coup
qui considère qu'ils ont quelque chose
de de d'intéressant il ont peut-être la
vendre à un meilleur prix c'est un
Français hein donc voilà ce n'est pas le
cas général mais ça peut arriver et puis
le le le le 3è la trème solution c'est
dire bon je vois bien que
je peux garder un Noot en France parce
que quand même je suis français j'ai
envie de vivre en France et cetera mais
la seule solution pour moi c'est de
prendre une partie de ma production et
de trouver un atelier étranger qui me
permette de travailler correctement
alors que je ne peux plus travailler en
France et et c'est ce cette troisème
solution que je vois se développer à
grande échelle aujourd'hui parce que les
les deux premières on y pas pas
grand-chose c'està dire que la première
j'ai envie d'avoir une niche je garde ma
niche je me bat je me bat ils VT
toujours se battre il y a des gens qui
se battront toujours jusqu'à jusqu'à la
dernière puis cass le nombre de patrons
qui suicide parce qu'il y arrivent plus
il y en a beaucoup quand même énorme
énorme la deuxième c'est dire je vends
je vois ça décupl décupler c'est
multiplier par 10 c'est c'est c'est
étonnant c'est étonnant mais pourquoi
vous vendez tu te rends pas compte
regarde un peu le prix d'énergie et le
prix de l'énergie a été un des éléments
importants comme l'a indiqué Nicolas
depuis le départ comme je l'ai souligné
aussi c'est-à-dire que passer de 50 à
200 ou à 300 EUR le mgawh c'est une
c'est c'est la marge qui s'en va et donc
c'est un c'est un coup c'est un coup sur
le nez extrêmement important c'est un
coup sur le nez que qui et qui n'a
absolument aucune raison
des coups sur la tête à un moment il
disent bon on va s'expliquer quand même
les patrons les petits patrons la la la
sève de notre pays
ils ont décidé un petit peu de
ont décidé d'être un peu plus
attraper le gouvernement par le callback
dis écoute moi tu es bien gentil à faire
à faire du bruit avec ta bouche payer
avec mes taxes maintenant tu es en train
de me tuer donc je te je vais t'afficher
publiquement je vais dire je vends la
boîte je exile fiscalement parce que en
plus tues mesures fiscales où on n
jamais payé autant d'impôts tu commences
à me casser les oignons c'est 25 ans 50
ans de ma vie et en plus de ça pour
payer des infirmières même pas 1500
balles ne pas reconnaître les pompiers
comme profession dangereuse et faire ton
kéké à faire des annonces à 450 millions
d'euros parce que tu vas tu vas
sponsoriser 3 km par jour à ton
travailleur et ça va te permettre de te
faire une super une super annonce les
petits patrons là il faut qu'ils se
prennent des cou sur le nez il se
rassemble fasse comment mais ils
sontment ve qu'il fasse regarde les Bou
boulang comment veux-tu qu'il fassent
les boulangers ont essayé il on essayer
ils sont montés une fois à Paris mais
ces mecsl ils bossent tous les jours ils
doivent sauver leur boîte ils peuvent
pas juste être à Paris faire des
manifestation ils sont combien ils sont
quoi 5000 quand le patron quand le
patron enlève s'enlève une journée ou
deux dans le mois pour faire autre chose
pour militer ou pour dire pour aller
voir les gens il se fait massacrer
lorsqu'il arrive et et puis son
entreprise il faut qu'il travaille le
weekend dedans donc il faut faut voir
sur les patrons d'aujourd'hui la plupart
des patrons d'aujourd'hui on réduit on
réduit on réduit leur salaire de façon
importante quand ils n'ont pas enlevé
complètement le nombre de le nombre de
gens de mes collègues qui disent de
toute façon cette année je me P pas
extrêmement élevé donc c'est la réalité
de ce pays c'est de érisation y compris
des patrons et et donc il faut remettre
ça dans la tête de tout le monde c'est
c'est je parle des petits patrons qui
font 85 % de
de l'emploi et 85 % de l'industrie
française c'est cela dont je parle et et
je dis ceuxl sont en en désérance
complètement et si jamais ils ont une
solution quand ils n'ont pas de PGE le
plan d'épargne et si jamais ils arrivent
encore à emprunter ils essayent de voir
comment comment ils peuvent enlever une
partie de leur production pour la mettre
dans un pays différent mais un pays
différent c'est c'est faut faut faut
bien voir ça peut être ça peut être la
Suisse l'Italie ou l'Allemagne un pays
différent hein c'est que je suis pas en
train de vous dire que tout le monde a
envie de partir très très loin dans des
pays à bas salaire et CEA non c'est pas
c'est pas ça le sujet le le B c'est
l'application des normes qui est
l'élément dominant on m'applique quelque
chose je ne peux pas le faire on
m'oblige à faire des choses et je n'ai
pas en face de moi des gens
bienveillants qui ont i de m'aider alors
tout à l'heure vous m'avez dit très
justement mais il y a quand même des
gens qui aident il y a des gens oui
qu'est-ce qu'ils aident on est on est
devenu et on essaie de N transformer en
peuple de mandiant c'est-à-dire qu'on
essaie de vous dire voilà euh mais vous
avez des subventions vous avez des
subventions alors si vous avez vous
faites alors on dit B on dématérialist
ah oui on dématérialiste c'est vrai
alors on commence par par faire ça par
euh euh
ordinateur et puis après on vous dit non
c'est 400 kg de papier minimum et vous
allez avir et puis après vous allez
passer devant une commission et puis une
autre commission et puis une autre
commission mais comment on fait quand on
ê un petit patron quand est un petit
patron qui doit être sur le terrain on
peut pas on peut pas balancer à faire ça
donc effectivement au bout du compte les
aides et subventions sont prises en
majorité par des entreprises qui ont la
capacité de de faire ou alors ou alors
il faut prendre quelqu'un qui va faire
le Doss à vot place quoi un chasseur de
subvention un chasseur de subvention les
startup alors c'est une sensu c'est une
sensu c'est c'est un parasite et ce
alors
donc voilà ce voilà ce qu'on fait bon
mais mais ça c'est pas c'est pas du à
quoi ça sert à quoi ça sert si jamais on
a une économie qui fonctionne
correctement on n pas besoin d'avoir des
chèqus des aides des subventions ça va
naturellement parce qu'on fait des
marges mais si on vous enlève les marges
parce que que on a une mauvaise
politique énergétique parce que ce n'est
qu' uniquement une mauvaise politique
puisque le prix de l'énergie électrique
le prix réel de l'g le coût l'énergie
électrique n'a pas augmenté ces derniers
temps parce qu'on a le nucléaire et
hydraulique donc le coût n'a pas
augmenté et le prix et le prix a
augmenté et le prix a augmenté pour des
raisons je dirais gouvernementale ou
régalienne mais pas du tout sur le plan
technique on a le même coût avec les
aujourd'hui qu'ier donc c'est C
pasugmentter et ça met l'ensemble de
l'industrie française en péril bon ça ça
mérite qu'on regarde ça mérite qu'on
regarde comment on fait alors les
Allemands disent ça nous met en péril
parce qu'on a on a déraillé pour ne pas
employer un autre mot sur l'éolien et le
gaz et la linite non très bien alors
pendant un certain nombre d'années on va
vous donner des subventions pour que le
prix de l'électricité corresponde à à à
la concurrence mais nous on a pas fait
ça on a on a dit le
le particulier va on va lui arranger son
coup alors 10 10 % seulement 25 % il
augmente quand même enfin on arrange son
coup pour essayer de garder un électorat
relativement flexible mais l'industrie a
pris plein la figure il a pris tro qu C
fois plus cher c'est ça la réxible calme
flexible ou calme flexible ou calme
l'électorat
bah calme calme calmé par le covid S dit
voilà on a plus plein la gueule sur le
covid ça continue bon voilà on y peut
rien et voilà il n pas il n pas il n'a
pas rallé il n pas vous souvenez que les
gilets jaunes ont rallé sur le prix de
l'essence et sur le 80 km/h voà mais
mais là on n pas eu on n pas eu la même
explosion
sur le Prix deélectricité Or ça a
augmenté effectivementz des bonnes
nouvelles là ou non mais juste je
voulais revenir sur bonne nouvelle la
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on pe revenir à
la réalité c'està dire si jamais vous
vous dites aux industriels français le
coût de l'électricité
est bon marché par conséquent vous allez
recevoir le prix correspondant à ce coût
une fois vous lui dites ça l'industriel
il est content ça baisse il est content
et il se dit je vais rester mais si on
continue à lui dire que le le prix va
augmenter parce que qu'on va aller vers
la vers la pénurie que ça va continuer à
augmenter qu'on aura jamais plus jamais
plus d'énergie abondante jamais plus
d'énergie bon marché il pourquoi je
reste en plus tous les autres pays sont
en train d'essayer de trou de régler ce
problème et nous notre pays règle pas et
et la façon dont il a réglé avec une
grande victoire c'est de dire en 2026 on
a une solution mais mais mais le
problème n'est pas la solution 2026
grande expérience de ta grande
expérience
tu as l'impression que c'est dû parce
que on est gouverné par des médiocres
ou que ça vient d'un principe de guerre
économique piloté depuis l'extérieur de
la France pour remettre la France basse
pour éviter que la France soit
dérangeante un peu plus tard est-ce que
est-ce que c'est incompatible
dis c'est oui nous sommes dirigés par
des gens méia en plus on se fait enfler
voilà c'est tout moi je pense que je met
tu m'as dit tu m'as dit oou je dis et
non mais après on on a satisit pas mais
bon c'est comme ça mais donc on a chance
de s'en sortir si jamais on a des forces
de de résistance vous AZ pas essayer des
trucs un peu plus fon genre faire un
calendrier de patron
pour faire payer vos frais d'avocat vous
avez pas essayé de faire des trucs comme
ça je te verrai bien un poil en noir et
blanc assis sur un cheval on a on a on a
ça bien sûr on a ça mais on a ça de
façon régionale il y a des régions qui
arrivent à s'en sortir la vender et
arrivrive à s'en s administré la Vendée
est bien administré mais la Vendé a ça
l'industrie venne a été fa autour de
cette solidarité entre les entre les
patrons et donc quand il y a un patron
quand il y a un patron qui est en
difficulté les autres essaient de voir
comment ils font mais c solidarité
n'existe pas partout il y a des endroits
où les patrons sont plutôt en rivalité
alors il y a des rivalités d'ego comme
chez moi en Bretagne Mo Bretagne
y a une solidarité mais il y a aussi
beaucoup de rivalités de rivalités qui
ne sont pas des rivalité industrielle
qui ont des rivalités d'ego tu es plus
connu que l'aut conseil c'est les
patrons vous allez déménager en vend et
il y aura un noyau dur c'est ça ok
Nicolas j'aimerais avoir des bonnes
nouvelles s'il vous plaît
en V en Alsace c'est pas mal le mélange
alsacien allemand marche bien avec la
Creuse au milieu les creuso il y a
beaucoup de choses à apprendre oui mais
mais il y a pas beaucoup d'industrie on
dit souvent non mais la la bonne
nouvelle la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on
dit souvent y il y avait on dit souvent
c'est l'Allemagne c'est l'Allemagne qui
a tout fait pour c'est les États-Unis et
cetera oui c'est vrai les États-Unis les
Allemandes défendent leurs intérêts le
problème c'est que nous ne défendons pas
les ntres non mais en plus d'avoir
défendu leurs intérêts si vous me
permettezfendu
intérêts ils nous ont un petit peu chié
dans les botes non
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi pas ils
défendent leurs intérêts défend intér
c'est à nous de chier dans de de leur
chier dans les bottes comme vous dites
et et de défendre nos intérêts on n pas
défendu nos intérêts pas défendu on se
couche sans arrêt c'est ça notre la
bonne nouvelle c'est que si on trouve
quelqu'un qui va défendre nos intérêts
on va s'en sortir pour l'instant on les
a pas voilà si d'avoir quelqu' la bonne
nouvelle c'est ça si jamais quelqu'un
défend nos intérêts une fois comm dirit
les Belges c'est bon mais c'est pas le
cas regardez on pas les regard on va
faire regardez agè panierunach qui ça AG
Pier
l'assistante de garciort la magie pour
le c'est ça elle a elle a elle a voulu
défendre nos intérêts sur cette
négociation du réforme du marché
européen et et elle a réussi très bien
donc bah oui c'est une bonne nouvelle
après elle a réussi on est incapable de
quantifier l'impact et je veux quand
même revenir sur un truc qui qui me gêne
et que j'ai envie de dire quand même ce
soir c'est que si aujourd'hui on a tant
d'industriels qui qui souffrent donc
c'est les petits ils sont protégés les
consomm les gros ils sont protégés et
tout ce qui est au milieu se fait
démolir
c'est en fait c'est à cause d'un calcul
d'un haut fonctionnaire de l'État hein
qui a oublié dans son calcul un petit
truc c'estàd que les prix qui ont
explosé ce sont des prix artificiels ce
sont pas les vrais prix parce que le
parc nucléaire il est pas changé du jour
au lendemain c'est le même parc
nucléaire c'est les mêmes barrages
hydrauliques l'électricité le marché
européen c'est 10 % de ce qu'on consomme
oublie pas qu'on avait un parc nucléaire
un peu en Caraf ouais ouais mais ça
change rien je vais te donner le prix
qu'on avait sur l'électricité le parc
c'est à peu près 60 70 € moi j'ai fait
un calcul l'an dernier au pire du pire
du pire éventuellement le coût moyen on
est monté à 100 € du mgawh mais c'est
quoi le prix qui est recommandé par la
creux l'organisme chargé de faire la
régulation c'est 240 € du mgawh donc
elle elle recommande deux fois et demi
le prix qui était déjà beaucoup plus
élevé donc quatre fois notre prix de
production et là on a un problème et
tout est prévu dans la loi pour sortir
de ce mécanisme pour sortir de ce calcul
qui est le calcul des tarifs réglementer
de l'électricité mais rien n'a été fait
on a laissé les tarifs explosés alors on
a protégé le consommateur madame padirun
nous dit oui vous comprenez je prends en
charge 37 % de votre facture
d'électricité mais elle oublie un mot je
prends en charge 37 % dere facture
artificiel d'électricité et avec votre
pognon avec votre pognon le bouclier
tarifaire c'est un bouclier
c'est un B artificiel c'est artificiel
sur un prix artificiel d'une facture
artificielle et c'est ça le scandale
d'État et c'est ça que personne dénonce
parce que malheureusement c'est un sujet
qui est un peu compliqué et moi
personnellement ça m'a pris du temps de
le comprendre on l'a dénoncé avec loï
avec carne monb Henry progliot Hervé
machenau dans une tribune en juin c'est
ce truc là qu'il fallait changer et moi
j'ai comme je pense qu'il faut pas non
plus jeter l'eau avec le dubain laarine
c'était pas si mal bébé avec l' du bain
le bébé avec l' du bain le laaren
c'était pas si mal et moi je proposais
de l'améliorer parce que qu'est-ce que
c'est la reen c'est vrai que tout le
monde dit il faut sortir du marché
européen c'est pas bien laaren et cetera
laaren c'est une dérogation qu'on a
obtenu de l'Union européenne pour que
notre prix l'électricité soit pas le
prix spot et qu'on ait la part nucléaire
qui soit à 2/3 il avait un certain
nombre soit à 2 ti3 et qu'on donne une
partie de l'électricité à des
fournisseurs alternatifs il avait un
certain nombre de petites choses qu'
avait mal été anticipé et c'est ça qui a
fait que les tarifs les tarifs ont les
tarifs ont explosé mais ça on aurait pu
le faire évoluer on aurait dû réagir
déjà il y a 2 ans moi ce qui me gêne
profondément c'est qu'en fait on a
sacrifié des industriels
avec des factures
artificielleélectricité mais eux leur
travail pas artificiel poon il arrivait
bien quelque part quand même comment ça
il AR quel part les factures artificiel
comme tu les décrit c'est est-ce que
est-ce que c'est à nous de faire les
flics et de savoir ce qu'il en est ou
est-ce ce que c'est à l'état de savoir
où V le fruc alors moi à chaque fois que
l'État me pose cette question vous avez
bien une idée
c'est à vous de faire c'est à vous de
dire c'est à vous de faire c'est votre
vous avez à faire votre boulot moi j'ai
pas à faire votre boulot moi je sais
d'où il est parti mais j'ai pas mais
c'est c'est pas moi de le dire mais
c'est à vous de faire et à vous d'agir
de façon à ce que effectivement nous
industriels nous payons le coup ou
quelque chose qui se rapproche du coup
et non pas quelque chose d'artificiel
c'est ça votre boulot tu tu vas me
conseiller un livre à lire un livre h
seulement alors trois
trois livres bon al bon les le le
dernier le dernier que j'ai lu et qui
est absolument fascinant c'est le de
Gaal de Jackson de GA de Jackon le maire
c'est ça quoi l'Axel le maire de GA BR
le ma de Gaul de Gaal de Jackson c'est
un livre fait 900 900 pages et qui est
absolument
absolument extraordinaire et qui reprend
comment de Gaulle en particulier a
repris une économie en difficulté et
comment il a redressé le pays en ayant
des objectifs et en tenant ses objectifs
quel jour on est aujourd'hui quoi quel
jour on est aujourd'hui tu parles de de
gaoule H tu parles de de gaoule on est
on est quel jour aujourd'hui
anniversaire de sa mort c'est ça non oui
9 novembre
et c'est et c'est un Liv absolument
extraordinaire à lire à lire aujourd'hui
parce que il est il est il est actuel
c'est qu'on on voit les alors les les
livre que que que j'aime bien c'est tous
les livres de de France Olivier Gisbert
sur la façon dont la la République c'est
c'est'est faite et et alors j'ai pas lu
le 3è j'attends de j'attends de de de le
recevoir pour et puis le troisième livre
que suggère c'est le livre sur les peurs
de Marie etelle du pont c'estàd que
c'est que pourquoi avons-nous peur
pourquoi avons-nous peur et qu'est-ce
qu'on est en train de donner à nos
enfant comme peur comme anxiété comm or
moi j'ai envie que les enfants qui qui
ne me survivront dans quelques années
ils ont envie de faire des choses ils
ont envie d'être d'être de d'agir de
d'entreprendre j'ai envie de ça et et on
on a on a fait avec l'époque du covid
mais surtout avec l'éco anxiété
permanente sur la peur que la planète
explose la peur que ceci la peur queela
des échos anxieux il faut absolument
qu'on réagisse par rapport à ça et et ce
livre vous permettra de aux uns et aux
autres de de comprendre que il faut
faire autrement et surtout tu as déjà
fait de la plongée tu as déjà fait de la
plongée sous-marine un peu dans tes
tendreuxes annéesoup beaucoup oui ou
jusqu'à ben j'en ai fait partout un peu
dans le monde enfin j'en fait surtout en
Bretagne surtout en Bretagne donc j'ai
commencé à j'ai commencé à faire de la
plongée sous-marine et la pêche
sous-marine et la pêche sous-marine à
l'âge de 12 ans et j'ai et j'ai arrêté
et j'ai arrêté quand quand quand mes
oreilles ont pété deux fois et donc yyo
quoi comment tu t'es fait pour faire
péter lesant tuavais j'étais j'étais un
peu chargéa
r j'avais un rume il y avait une an ave
il y avait une encre qui était coincée
je suis allé décoincer l' 4 m qu combien
4 m 15 m 15 m
et donc et donc maintenant je aller
maintenant quand je vais dans l'eau
quand je nage j'essaie de mettre la tête
un peu hors de l'eau de façon à ce que
l'eau ne rentre pas dans l'ORE parce ch
donc tu as fait beaucoup de plongé
sous-marine mais en plongur bien
essentiellement
ch à Gachon ou bien en en tant que
chasseur à la Gachon quand tu te plques
dans ton trou àard tu as Paris la tête
sous l'au depuis longtemps mais tu as
bien vu quand même que il y avait des
sacs plastiques il y a des masques un
peu partout que l'eau de la mer se
réchauffé un peu partout tu as bien vu
que même en Méditerranée
je suis pas un spécialiste Méditerranée
excuse-moi d'accord
il fael en Bretagne en Bretagne en
Bretagne je suis je suis à 15 degr quand
j'étais jeune jeis 15
changé ou pas non non le cycle de
reproduction desomars il a il a changé
non non pas vraiment non il a non ce qui
a changé c'est que il y a il y a eu une
période on avait de la langousste en
Bretagne qui était absolument
extraordinaire que maintenant la
langouse est revenue mais j'ai je n'ai
pas retrouvver le le goût de la
langouste de de mon enfance je pas
retrouvé pasouvé peut-être je
retrouverai j'achète la langouste
partout dans tous les pays où je suis
Allis à chaque fois que jeis quelque
part je suis allé en Tunisie récemment
j'ai mangé la j'ai pas j'ai pas c'est
peut-être parce que tu as VI h c'est
peut-être parce que tu vie ah non non
pas du tout parce que parce que je je
retrouve je retrouve je retrouve le goût
le goût de l'araignée de mer par exemple
qui est un femelle femelle femelle le
mal aussi les deux les deux les deux
c'est extraordinaire ça a un goût
exceptionnel il y a pas de vieill
langoues il a que des langoues prudentes
non voilà donc donc j'ai fait j'ai fait
effectivement de la pêche de la pêche
Mar très longtemps jusqu'au moment où
j'ai pu pu en faire à cause orilles tu
as bien vu en mettant la tête sous l'eau
quand même ça a changé depuis que tu
étais jeune non a un petit peu de
dérèglement de pollution un peu partout
quand même non tu le vois quand même
disons que la la nature bretonne euh
change quasiment tous les ans
aujourd'hui avec des nouvelles algues
des on s'aperçoit des des nouveaux des
nouveaux trucs des nouveaux des des
nouveaux des des nouveaux trucs qui
arrivent et on sait pas on ne sait pas
trop pourquoi pourquoi ils sont là j'ai
j'ai j'ai vu des là le dernier coup j'ai
vu dans une Mar j'ai trouvé un poisson
qui était que j'avais jamais vu avant un
poisson tropical qui était là pourquoi
il est revenu par là pourtant l'eau
n'est pas n'est pas d'une ch question
Internet le kilofloc prigant connais-il
les bactéries sulfatéductrice
qui ronge l'inox j'ai entendu parler de
ça non les bactéries je connais un
conseil pour les jeunes générations
loïque oui génération ayez n'ayez pas
peur arrêtez c'est pour ça que je vous
ai je conseille le livre h
pas peur et faites les choses don vous
avez envie je voudrais vis que les
gensil j'ai envie de ça et je vais
réussir dans ce que j'ai envie de faire
et je vois des des des gosses qui
arrivent qui arrivent dans dans dans
dans mes installations dans mes usines
et et qui ont
qui ont pas envie quoi pas envie tu fais
du mentoring bien sûr tu as combien de
padawan en ce moment sous ton aile
combien de de jeunes que tu protèges
sous ton aile en ce moment oh c'est une
bonne dizaine ouais
Nicolas TR bouquins conseil pour les
jeunes générations trois bouquins je
vais peut-être commencer par deux mais
le problème c'est que j'ai j'ai plus les
titres je peut-être demander de l' à
lïic il y en a un premier parce que
c'est des livres que j'ai lu récemment
et comme j'ai pas je trouve je trouve le
temps de Oui Oui est au ministère des
Finances non donc un livre de F bien
googl les Guer la Guer deg toqu d'ors la
guerre de l'énergie la guerre de
l'énergie la guerre c'est la guerre de
l'énergie fa BL bien Boulé ça c'est ça
c'est sympa Fabi bien Bouglé
un autre livre donc sur toutes les
guerre de l'énergie et c'est oui oui
fait de la politique énergétique alors
euh François la planification
énergétique ça c'est sur l'Ukraine et
comment s'appelle le livre c'est non
c'est sur le le choc des civilisations
j'ai pas le titre la guerre la guerre la
François Martin un livre qui retiréraine
qui part de l'Ukraine mais qui explique
surtout le grand l'accélération du grand
basculement géopolitique de l'Occident
vers les pays vers les pays de France
l'Ukraine est le basculement du monde
voilà c'est ça tu vois c'est aussi
François Martin voilà exactement
l'Ukraine ça inessant ça montre un petit
peu le cétais pas si mauvais voilà
continue et et puis le trème on va finir
avec un petit classique parce que c'est
pas mal pour se se sensibiliser oui oui
é à l'Élysée voilà non euh non j'aurais
pu dire le prochain livre de Philippe
bwix mais je veux pas faire de spoiling
et je l'ai pas encore lu non le
la bande dessinée de Jean-Marc Ji le
monde sans fin c'est c'est un bon
classiquee
ça c'est sympa je un 4e je en prendre un
4 si plastique Bing plastique Bing de
taille àtion
[Rires]
compris que tu prêchais pour le
plastique à T raison il prêche pour le
recyclage du plastique recyclage du
plastique je je dis il faut recycler le
plastique le plastique est recycl voilà
mais nous on empêche le recyclage on
empêche le recyclage en France c'est
c'est ça la réalité bon jeou une
parenthèse le conseil pour les jeunes
générations Petit Nico ben moi j'aimais
bien le conseil de loïque euh et et
c'est vrai que moi il y a un truc qui
qui me rend un peu dingue c'est c'est
l'écoanxiété et je pourquoi la
solastagie je me je me rends compte que
moi j'ai passé mon bac en en 98 et qu'à
l'époque j'étais pas B 18 ans B non 17
ans ouaisou c'est pas mal bon ça va hein
tout le monde a un an de retard non 17
ans c'est à 16 ans qu'on passe en France
normalement et donc et donc provocation
inutile et donc à l'époque on était pas
bombardé toute la journée par des
nouvelles on avait pas les chaînes
d'affond en continue on n parlait pas de
climat de la plante qui allait mourir et
cetera et aujourd'hui mais c'est ça
l'univers dans lequel on a tous nos
jeunes Alice ils se prennent ils se
prennent ces mauvaises nouvelles en
permanence ils sont pris le covid on les
enfermé pendant 2 ans chez eux et donc
c'est c'est très compliqué et donc le
Conseil euh de la bouche pour les pour
les jeunes générations c'est peut-être
de pas trop allumer la télé hein éviter
ça euh au maximum d'ailleurs euh se
relaxer un petit peu avec les C anxiété
parce qu'en fait l'homme il a 40000 ans
donc oui on a des challenges oui avec le
climat oui avec l'énergie mais on va
s'adapter euh par contre si on fait rien
et qu'on est dans notre coin
effectivement ça va pas se passer tout
seul mais on va s'adapter ça va être
plus ou moins douloureux mais il s'agit
juste de changer de comportement et ça
va bien se passer etiste
le le le conseil que je donne qui est
assez basique finalement c'est et que
j'aimerais bien faire plus souvent mais
que j'arrive pas c'est lisez des livres
le soir vous rentrez chez vous c'est
tellement facile de prendre son
téléphone de regarder les réseaux
sociaux Twitter et je suis le premier à
le faire ouvrez un livre ouvrez des
livres lisez-les passez plus de temps
sur votre livre et moins de temps sur
votre téléphone c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que à chaque interview on demande à nos
invités de conseiller trois livres
messieurs je vous remercie pour cette
petite interview qui met du Bob au cœur
avec tellement de bonnes nouvelles et
des conseils pour notre administration
pour laisser les patrons un peu essayer
de redresser notre pays je vous souhaite
une excellente soirée merci merci
[Musique]